So, Leute.
The Silent Pain ist am Start.
11 Monate in Folge.
Poggers.
Was soll der Titel derweil? Stimmt.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz die Fragen vom letzten Mal noch aufräumen.
Da blicke ich da aber an,
aber dadurch, was ich schon beantwortet habe, war es nett.
Das haben wir eh vor.
Die Frage kommt immer wieder.
Das müsste man eigentlich mal als Kommando beantworten.
BSPWM testen.
Ich habe gehört,
dass es alles bloatet.
Alles bloatet.
Laut Twitch existiert der übrigens gar nicht.
Laut Twitch habe ich null Zuschauer.
Alles bloatet.
Ich habe letztens ein Video geguckt,
der gesagt hat,
alles bloatet außer DWM.
Allerdings sehe ich
den Grund überhaupt nicht zu wechseln.
Ich finde
E3 eigentlich super.
E3 hat fast alles defaultmäßig,
so wie ich es haben will.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund.
Alles bloatet.
Oh Gott, ich habe letztens ich habe gestern Abend wollte ich das hier gerade sehen.
Ich habe gestern Abend das hätte ich nicht machen sollen.
Das war nicht gut für meine Gehirnzellen.
Ich habe das.
Ich habe eine halbe Stunde das Video geguckt von vom Inscope 21 Niko.
Und wie heißt der andere, der dabei ist?
Gabel oder so kann das sein?
Schon wieder.
Nee, nee.
Heute.
Heute zum zum zum.
Glück kein kein C++.
Das ist noch auf vom letzten Mal.
So, gleich mal wieder zu C++, aber ich hätte es nicht machen soll.
Ich hätte mir das nicht angucken soll,
aber das hat mir mal wieder die Abgründe von YouTube Deutschland gezeigt.
Und nicht nur von YouTube Deutschland.
Ja, aber überhaupt.
Kennst du dich ein bisschen mit Dark Souls aus?
Naja, habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Tja, die Basics.
Ja, oh Mann.
Das hat echt weh.
Getan, das Video.
Ich habe es auch nicht ganz angeguckt.
Ich habe ein bisschen drüber geskippt und ich habe dann ich konnte mir den Scheiß nicht
mehr geben.
Ja, das ist, das ist so Leute, den KLS-Song, nein, nein, nein, nein, den kenne ich nicht
und ich will den auch nicht hören, Alter, hör auf, hör auf.
Aber du hast mitbekommen, dass die beiden verarscht wurden.
Ja, ja, wie gesagt, das Video meine ich ja, das habe ich mir gestern Abend angeguckt.
Das hat mir wieder die kompletten Abgründe von YouTube.
Und, ähm, diesen ganzen, da ist er da, das ist ja da nicht der Einzige.
Es gibt so viel, guck mal, ich habe, ich habe letztes, ich habe ein Video gesehen, denkst
dir, Simon Des, äh, nicht Desmond, wie heißt er, Simon Desue, der hat jetzt auch irgend
so eine komische Instagram Academy, wo du die krassen Influencer-Tricks lernst und sowas.
Warte, ich habe einen Piss-Dich-Alte.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist ein Piss-Dich-Alte.
Das ist ein, das ist ein Fehler von, mit Framethrows, warum heißt das Piss-Dich-Alte-Kombi.png
und hier unten ist das Original Piss-Dich-Alte.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, was ist das?
Das kann ich mir, ich kann, ich, vor allem, wie sich die Leute dann teilweise immer verarschen
lassen, ne?
So geil.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht das bezogen auf die Geschichte mit dem Video, was ich vom
Nico geguckt habe, sondern allgemein, dass da so viele drauf reinfallen.
Ja.
Also, also,令 семь, vier gardener stellen, immer noch.
Alter, komm in die Instagram-Gruppe.
Ne, nicht Instagram-Gruppe, was ist es?
WhatsApp-Gruppe.
Training.
Und du machst, drei, fünf, 5 000 Euro am Tag.
Bam, Bam, Bam.
Cash, Leute.
Cash.
Das krasse Business wird gestartet.
Kommt mal klar auf euer Leben, das krasse Business, komm in die Gruppe, das ist so
ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
Das da, die Masche ist ja auch nicht neu.
Ich meine, das, das ist eine WhatsApp-Gruppe ist es.
WhatsApp-Gruppe ist es neu, aber unterm Strich sind das meistens in irgendeiner Art und Weise irgendwelche Schneeballsysteme, die man ja offiziell, wie nennt man das, Struktur-Marketing, nee, ach, keine Ahnung, aber im Prinzip sind es ja fast alles sowas wie Schneeballsysteme.
Und dass da die Leute heute noch drauf reinfallen, die Holländer haben es erfunden, ja, das stimmt, warum ist jetzt auf einmal überall ein Kek-W hinten dran, jetzt ist es weg, also immer, ähm, gibt es hier ne Wette, dass die Bandbreite wieder einbricht, das können wir tatsächlich mal machen,
wir können jetzt, wir können jetzt, wann kackt Vodafone?
Wieder ab, ähm, jetzt bis 30 Minuten, wir sind ja wieder bloß bis 22 Uhr, also sagen wir mal so, in 30 Minuten, in 60 Minuten oder in 90 Minuten, also wer am nächsten, also das, es zählt das, was am nächsten dran ist, ne, es zählt das, was am nächsten dran ist, Multiple Choice, wo ist denn der Sinn davon, okay, jetzt machen wir, das wird der sinnvollste Vote überhaupt, wir machen Multiple Choice,
Leute, Multiple Choice Vote, das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll, ja, also ich tippe auch auf alles, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal, wie gut wir sind, lassen wir mal laufen, lassen wir mal laufen, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, was da rauskommt, noch geht's, ja, aber was, was gibt es dazu zu sagen, also ich, für mich ist unbegreiflich, dass dieser Scheiß immer noch so gut funktioniert, ja, ähm,
es ist immer die gleiche Masche, dass du heute noch, dass du heute noch ein Video drehen kannst, wo du dann hier dick die, dick die Scheine von der Hand runterwedelst und, und, und, äh, mit dem dicken Porsche reingefahren kommst ins Video und sagst, hey, das schreit schon so meilenweit Scam einem entgegen, dass ich nicht nachvollziehen kann, wie da heute überhaupt noch einer reinfällt,
kennst du von Steuerung F, Control F, das Video dazu, wo sie nach den Ziellosen, das kommt mir, ja, klar, kenn ich das, das hab ich sogar mal, irgendwann, ja, ja, das hab ich geguckt, hast du noch Kontakt mit dem Friseur, dem geht's gut, der spielt, äh, Mobile Games, was auch immer, ja, und, ich mein, der Scam ist überall, guckt euch die indischen Microsoft-Mitarbeiter an, der Scam ist überall,
was ich aber sehr fragwürdig finde, ganz ehrlich, und wie ich nicht verstehen kann, dass das wirklich Leute unterstützen und es Leute auch noch irgendwie abfeiern ist, wenn dann jemand wie, sagen wir mal, Simon Desue daherkommt, der im Prinzip damit noch schlimmer, als, sagen wir jetzt mal, irgendwie eine Bibi-Beauty-Palace oder was auch immer, einzig und allein darauf aus, dass seine Zuschauer auch noch, auch noch die Leute, die ihn quasi zu dem machen, was er ist, abzuzocken.
Und das ist halt echt bescheuert, ja, also, da musst du wahrscheinlich komplett skrupellos sein, dass du das machen kannst, also, gerade die Leute, die dafür sorgen, dass er überhaupt in irgendeiner Art und Weise relevant ist, oh, da Tainzer heute wieder, what the fuck, Alter, jetzt geht's aber ab hier, Poggers, ey.
Fünf Subs, Tainzer, dankeschön, nice, huge, massive IQ heute wieder, massive, also, der Chat tippt drauf, dass in 60 Minuten das abkackt, okay.
Auf wann das erstellt wurde, vor zwei Minuten, okay, das sieht man wunderbar.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs, wen haben wir da jetzt heute neu dabei?
Winnie.de, excellent, ähm, CaptainSiekai, AndiTechtGear, ElevenCore und TheRezis, bekommen alle Namen halbwegs bekannt vor, die sehe ich ja öfters, das ist also schon mal wahnsinnig pock, da hat es die Richtigen getroffen, sehr nice.
Ja, ha, ha, ha, Wojak.
Man kann überall Sachen reininterpretieren, ja, das stimmt.
Ah, Poggers, Subscription hier.
Und das, obwohl du und der Nico vor acht Jahren schon der Meinung wart, dass MapPacks Scams sind.
Was haben wir eigentlich, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wir haben mal eins, zwei Videos zusammen aufgenommen, aber ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer mehr, über was wir da geredet haben.
Ich hab gar keinen blassen Schimmer mehr.
Zu MW...
Ja, Firing Range.
Oh, oh, das Video kam nicht gut an.
Mach an, nee.
Will jetzt keine olle Videos gucken.
Hat nur grad zum Thema gepasst.
Musik, Musik passt eigentlich von der Lautstärke her.
Leute, der Titel vom Stream ist, schlechter Streamer feels Batman.
Ist euch das aufgefallen?
Und da muss ich sagen, das stimmt.
Der Stream ist übel schlecht.
Ich hab mir letztens mal, als ich im Bett gelegen hab, weil mein Alten nen Stream, nen Watt von mir angemacht und ich fand meinen Stream schlecht, weil, ich hab mir das sogar aufgeschrieben, warum ich meinen Stream schlecht fand.
Erstens, weil ich seit zwei Jahren oder so nicht geschafft habe, Custom Emotes zu machen, obwohl ich 25 Emote Slots habe oder so.
Ähm, das nächste ist, das nächste ist, weil ich keinen festen Streamplan habe, wie alle guten Streamer, zumindest so halbwegs, aber das kann ich nicht machen, weil dann, den halt ich eh nicht ein, weil ich, ihr wisst, wenn ich nen Streamplan mache, ähm, wenn ich nen Streamplan mache, dann ist, mach ich, halt ich mich da morgen nicht dran.
So, und das dritte ist, Streamplan ist eh Bullshit.
Naja.
Sehe ich, also rein aus, aus, wie soll ich sagen, so, so, Stonks Sicht, ist ein Streamplan das Beste, was man machen kann.
Ein Streamplan oder eben, dass die Leute regelmäßig, oder dass die Leute halt wissen, dass du da bist.
Das ist, das ist, äh, nicht, nicht schlecht, ja.
Das bringt, das bringt, das bringt viel.
Das, das bringt, das bringt viel.
Aber ich halt, ich halt mich ja eh nicht dran im Endeffekt, also, so kann ich das schon mal vergessen.
Ähm, so, und das dritte ist, und das ist heute auch wieder so ein Stream.
Ähm, ich hab, wenn ich online gehe, seitdem ich jetzt wieder mehr Streams mache, so, als ich eben, als ich, als ich dann teilweise noch ein, zwei Streams die Woche gemacht hab, da hab ich mir immer was überlegt, was wir im Stream machen können, ja.
Aber, ich geh mittlerweile so oft einfach on, ohne dass ich weiß, was ich machen soll, dass es im Endeffekt darauf rausläuft, dass ich den ganz, die ganze Zeit eigentlich nur da sitze.
Chat lese, und, dann auf irgendwelche Sachen eingehe, die der Chat schreibt.
Du kannst dir mal endlich Unity angucken, weil, wollte ich mit, weil, was, ich wollte mir doch kein Unity angucken.
Kommst, willkommen.
So.
Und deswegen suckt der Stream.
So macht die Politik doch auch, ja.
Das stimmt.
Chat Interaction, das muss man sagen, das funktioniert ja auch wirklich gut.
Ähm, also, die, die Chat Interaction ist zum größten Teil massive.
Also, ich sehe wenig Streams mit, sag mal so, 100 bis 200 Zuschauern.
Bist ja bei mir auch meistens, sonntags ist meistens ein bisschen mehr.
Mach Coding Reviews.
Ja, schickt mir euren Source Code, und ich review.
Oh, das ist ne gute Idee, Tobi, das ist ne gute.
Dann kann ich das im Stream machen, was ich auf der Arbeit auch den ganzen Tag mach.
Excellent.
Ähm, oh, der Kobolern Stream.
Ja.
Den machen wir, den machen wir aber wirklich noch.
Den machen wir aber wirklich noch.
Oh, das ist doch, das ist dein Minecraft-Klon-Projekt mit 20.000 Zeilen, oder?
Wie soll ich das reviewen jetzt im Stream nebenbei?
Das ist, das ist das, wo, wo, wo du massig, massig Zeug drin hast, ja.
Okay, also, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Gucken wir uns gleich an.
Ich muss jetzt erst noch mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen was loswerden.
120.000 Zeilen, nee, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Wir gucken uns da vielleicht, wir gucken uns da vielleicht,
ein, oh, der Fucker da.
Meta?
Was ist das?
Sieht aus wie, sieht aus wie ein Jammel.
Wo, wo ist dein Source-Code?
Assets?
Ist das Unity?
Zu Unity kann ich überhaupt, what the?
Ah, hier.
Da zu Unity, äh, zu Unity-Sachen kann ich wirklich nix sagen.
Ich könnte, ich könnte höchstens was zu ein bisschen, bisschen dem, dem C-Sharp-Style sagen,
aber ich geh mal davon aus, wenn du sowas auf, zum Laufen kriegst, hast du damit wenig, wenig Schmerzen.
Unity ist C-Sharp, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Reviews, du meinst, so war das nicht gemeint.
Und je nachdem, was bin ich da auch nicht der Richtige für?
Jetzt null Geschleime, aber du bist aktuell mein Fav-Streamer geworden.
Oh, excellent.
Nice, das finde ich gut.
Ich bin extremst aktiv auf Twitch und du bist der Einzige, bei dem man merkt, dass es echt nicht dumm ist,
sehr interessanten Content macht.
Okay, das ehrt mich, ja, aber ich muss sagen, es ist halt komplett planlos von meiner Seite.
Weil, also, ich, ich, ich geh einfach auf und mach irgendwas.
Aber wenn das funktioniert, ist gut.
Excellent.
Bist du, was, bist du sonst auch so ein fauler Mensch?
Keck weh.
Äh, also, ich, komplett, komplett true.
Allerdings würde ich nicht sagen true keck weh, sondern true lull weh.
Ja, bin ich. Extrem faul, Alter.
Ich bin so faul, das geht gar nicht.
Ja.
Ich bin so faul, dass ich einen YouTube-Channel mit fast 300.000 Subs vergammeln lasse,
dass ich mich null drum kümmere um irgendwelche Sachen
und, ähm, dass ich den ganzen Tag eigentlich nur sinnlos Twitch gucke, YouTube gucke,
gucke, was es auf Steam Neues gibt, irgendwelchen dummen, dummen Origin of irgendwelchen Memes mir angucke
und eigentlich nix Gescheites mache.
Wann unterschreibst du bei Raid Shadow Legends?
Die haben tatsächlich schon gefragt, ja.
Ich dachte, du hast einen Job.
Ja, außer, außerhalb von meinem Job ist das so.
Ich hab gehört, es soll helfen, mehr Sport zu machen, mehr Motivation zu nehmen.
Nee, ich war schon immer so.
Auch früher, wo ich mehr Sport gemacht habe, das war schon immer so.
Ich hab mich...
Ich drücke mich immer extrem vor Arbeit.
Ich muss sagen, das ist aber auch nicht die allerschlechteste Eigenschaft, weil ich bin da an sich das, was ich...
Also, wenn ich...
Also, wenn ich was mache, dann mache ich es meistens ganz gut, sodass ich es halt nicht nochmal machen muss.
Das machen aber alle faulen Leute so.
Weil die meisten faulen Leute sind relativ so.
Und das liegt daran, das musst du sein, weil sonst musst du die Sache doppelt und dreifach machen.
Work smart, not hard. Genau.
Hast du schon mal PS2 und PS3 Emulatoren getestet?
Ja, habe ich.
Aber das kann ich nicht, das kann ich nicht im Stream machen.
Das geht leider nicht im Stream.
Das wird mit RetroPie schon schwierig.
Weil da brauchst du ja immer irgendwelche...
Also, du brauchst einmal die ganzen ROMs.
Und du brauchst ja auch, zumindest bei der PS1, hat man auch irgendwelche BIOS-Files gebraucht und sowas.
Dein YouTube-Kanal ist noch top aktuell wie die deutsche Bahn.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Ne, also das bringt bei mir nix.
Das war schon immer so.
So.
On-Stream-Emulator von Scratch NC programmieren.
Kann ich nicht.
Trotz Kappa.
Also ich weiß prinzipiell, wie ein Emulator funktioniert, aber ich traue mir nicht zu, sowas zu basteln.
Ich meine, was relativ easy ist, wenn man beispielsweise für den Gameboy was macht, wo man rein die ROM-Files einlesen kann.
Allerdings dann die ROMs ausführen eher nicht.
Zockst du well?
Ich hab's mir überlegt.
Ob ich da nicht...
Weil ich brauch unbedingt ein Spiel, wo ich mal wirklich ein bisschen reinsuchen kann wieder.
Das liegt auch daran, dass ich so wenig motiviert bin, weil ich kein gescheites Game hab.
Wie gesagt, die Season Pass of Exile hat mich jetzt ja nicht so...
Wo ist das überhaupt?
Ah, hier.
Die Season Pass of Exile hat mich irgendwie jetzt nicht so abgeholt.
Und...
Valorant ist eigentlich das Einzige...
Ich hab zwei Sachen zur Auswahl.
Also ich hab zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, was was spielt.
Was das Spiel angeht.
Ähm...
Entweder Battlefield 5...
Ah, ganz bestimmte.
Hähähä.
Ähm...
Genau.
Also...
Die...
Die Sache ist die...
Entweder...
Fang ich echt mal mit Warzone an.
Ich mein, ich hab das Game.
Man braucht es ja noch nicht, weil es ist ja Free-to-Play.
Oder...
Oder ich fang echt ein bisschen an Valorant zu spielen.
Wobei...
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, dass ich eher zu Valorant tendiere, weil Call of Duty auf dem PC immer so ein Ding ist.
Weil Call of Duty auf dem PC immer so ein Ding ist.
Oder wir spielen Raid Shadow Legends.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus.
Ich habe gehört, vielleicht spielt ja jemand von euch Warzone auf dem PC.
Was habe ich mit der Musik los? Ist die nicht viel zu laut oder passt das?
Ah, scheint, scheint. Ah, das müsste eigentlich gehen.
Also, auf dem PC soll es wohl ziemlich viele Cheater in Warzone geben.
Valorant ist toxic as fuck. Das stört mich nicht.
Das bin ich schon von Overwatch gewöhnt.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht, dass es mich nicht stört. Das stört mich.
Aber ich kann das ignoren mittlerweile.
Also, und mehr als Overwatch ranked, kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das toxic ist.
Das sind ja die gleichen Leute im Endeffekt.
Die gleichen toxic Spasten aus Overwatch ranked sind ja auch in Valorant ranked am Start.
Haha, geil. Ernsthaft? Cool.
Was ich mitgekriegt habe, ist, dass der Valorant Anti-Cheat manchmal ein bisschen über die Stränge schlägt
und, ähm, ähm...
Tom Mixwell haben sie gebannt, weil er sein Handy geladen hat am Rechner.
Da hat er sein Handy per USB angeschlossen. Bam. Anti-Cheat-Block.
Keck W. Keck W.
Excellent. Der USB-Aufladen ist auch hochkritisch.
Ja, vielleicht spiele ich doch mal eine Runde Warzone.
Allerdings nicht im Stream, sondern so ein bisschen für mich.
Ich muss ja immer erst ein bisschen in die Games reinkommen, weil ich kriege Anfälle.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt.
Wenn ihr mal ganz gut gewesen seid in bestimmten Games,
man kriegt Anfälle, wenn man wieder anfängt zu spielen und abgrundtief sackt.
Da muss man wirklich erstmal dranbleiben und zwei, drei Tage wieder wirklich ordentlich Stunden reinstecken,
dass man wieder gut wird. Und dann geht's auch wieder.
Dann geht's auch wieder.
Aber umso besser man mal in einem Game war, umso mehr fuckt es ab, wenn man...
ähm...
wenn man sackt.
Weil man selbst versteht das Game ja noch, weil man hat ja die Games eine Weile gespielt.
Man versteht selber, dass man sackt. Und das ist scheiße.
Das Problem haben die Leute, die immer sacken, nicht.
Die denken halt, okay, ist halt so wie immer.
Blocked HW-Monitor.
War ein HW-Monitor nochmal. Ist das das? Ist das dieses Benchmark-Ding?
Ach, das Ding.
Das verwendet noch jemand.
Poggers.
Hab ich, glaub ich, auch noch drauf, oder?
HW?
Ne, hab ich nicht drauf.
Oh, doch.
Was spricht eigentlich gegen ein Anti-Cheat-Tool, was zum Beispiel das Aim-Verhalten ETC live analysiert
und an dessen Hacker Schlussfolger...
Äh, nix, nix.
Ich persönlich gehe ja eh davon aus, dass in Zukunft vieles, was Anti-Cheat sein wird,
auch darauf basiert, dass die Serverseite, also Statistik-Auswertung machen.
Dass die irgendwelche AI, ähm, Training-Geschichten, Statistik-Auswertung machen.
Das geht bei manchen Sachen total einfach.
Sei es zum Beispiel bei, bei Accuracy oder was weiß ich wie.
Wie genau ist der und der mit der Waffe?
Und wenn du halt welche hast, die, ähm, in den Situationen deutlich genauer sind, reproduzierbar als die besten Spieler der Welt,
da weißt du, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Ähm, ja genau, es gibt ja schon, gibt ja schon die ersten.
Die, die das machen.
Natürlich muss das, natürlich muss das gescheit gemacht sein.
Nicht so wie das, weil ich es gerade sehe im Chat, nicht so wie das teilweise in Battlefield 4 gemacht ist.
Ähm, wo dann irgendwelche Leute, die selbst scheiße sind, ähm, irgendwelche, äh, Limits einstellen für ihren Server
und dann wirst du gekickt, weil du mal gut spielst oder mal, äh, glücklicherweise 8 Leute gleichzeitig gekillt hast mit irgendeinem
Revolution-Ding.
Äh, das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich für den Arsch.
Ich wurde auch auf vielen, äh, auf vielen, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Äh, äh, äh, äh.
Ich wurde auf vielen Servern gebannt in Battlefield, ähm, oder zumindest gekickt.
Aber, das, äh, sollte so nicht sein.
Also, wenn das ordentlich funktioniert, ist das, glaube ich, die Zukunft, was Anti-Cheat angeht.
Hast du das gesehen, wo der Typ seinen Lichter mit seiner ESP32-Zahnbürste steuert?
Nee.
Zeig mal.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Am Ende des Streams oder irgendwann XP-Installationsmusik spielen?
Was?
Warum?
Und jetzt?
So, perfekt.
Jetzt haben wir nur XP-Start-Sound gespielt.
Nee, Installation, Moment, was?
Das ist was anderes?
Die hab ich nie gehört, weil ich, weil meine Soundkarte erst nach der Installation funktioniert hat.
Okay.
Windows XP Installation Music.
Das hat, das hatte einen Sound beim Installieren, wirklich?
What?
Hab ich nie gehört.
Hat das irgendjemand schon mal gehört?
Ah, yes.
Besser als Cortana, das stimmt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Windows XP eine Installationsmusik hatte.
Wie gesagt, meine Soundkarte ging immer erst nach dem Installieren.
Ja, in Virtualbox.
Ich hab, glaube ich, noch nie Windows XP in Virtualbox oder auf Vmware installiert.
Am besten ist immer noch das hier gewesen.
Windows 98, ähm, Music Wizard.
Der, der, der.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das, das hier, das hier.
Warte mal, das hier.
Auf.
Ja.
Kommt gleich.
Oder?
Ja, genau.
Ah.
Das ist so, so richtig.
Möchte gern 90er Jahre, wir sind cool Musik.
So richtig, richtig schlecht eigentlich.
Aber generell, die Werbung aus den, so die 90er, Anfang 2000er,
die Werbung, die war halt, auch für Technik Sachen, die war halt auch immer ultra cringe.
Die haben so versucht, so übelst auf, auf Geek und, und, und cool und Hexer zu machen.
Und das hat nie hingehauen.
Das ist so, wie wenn heute die Firmen versuchen, auf, auf, auf Influencer Zeugs zu machen und,
und coole Sprüche für die Jugend von heute abzulassen.
Okay, was ist das denn?
Oh je, darf man das?
Kann man das zeigen?
Nicht, dass er jetzt gleich.
Nicht Monka, Monka Toss kommt, oder?
Okay, Moment, was?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Der steuert seinen Fernseher mit der, mit der Zahnbürste?
What?
Warum?
Geil.
Weil es geht, Alter.
Äh, Moment.
Die gleiche Zahnbürste habe ich auch.
Das heißt, ich könnte das auch machen?
Ich habe so eine Bluetooth.
Leute, die kennt ihr doch.
Ich habe da eine Bluetooth Zahnbürste.
Gamer Zahnbürste.
Die kennt ihr doch.
Moment.
Zahnbürste.
Hier, die Pro Gamer Zahnbürste.
Das ist die.
Guck mal.
Warte mal ab.
Hier.
Bluetooth Wireless Smart Guide.
Das ist die.
Moment, wo sieht man sie denn?
Hier.
Das ist Bluetooth Zahnbürste.
Trifi.
Genau.
Das Video hätte mal ein bisschen mehr Views kriegen können.
Ich meine, das ist immerhin die Pro Gamer Zahnbürste.
Wie ich das erst mal auf meinem Tisch unboxed habe.
Hier sieht man es.
Hier, Bluetooth.
Bluetooth.
Muss ja Bluetooth sein, weil man kann das ja auch mit der App, mit der App pairen.
Das ist die gleiche.
Bloß, dass er die in weiß, äh, in, in, in, in, in, in, in weiß hat.
Wofür Bluetooth, ähm, das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Das ist echt eine gute Idee.
An Home Automation anbinden.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, wozu.
Aber die Idee finde ich gut.
Ähm, wozu das Bluetooth da ist.
Das Ding hat eine App.
Ich zeige euch mal.
Ich versuche euch mal.
Guckt mal, ob es ein Bild davon gibt.
Das Ding hat eine App.
Ähm, wo man.
Ja, man sieht halt nicht sonderlich viel.
Hier, da ist sie.
Das Ding hat eine App, die dir quasi sagt, wo du wie lange Zähne putzen musst.
Und, ähm, sagt dann auch, wenn du zu fest drauf drückst.
Und du kannst angeblich irgendwie auch das Zahnputzprogramm von deinem Zahnarzt.
Definieren lassen und sowas.
Also eigentlich, eigentlich totaler Schwachsinn, ja.
Ähm, du kannst in der, äh, in der App selbst natürlich bürsten und Zahnpasta, Oral-B-Produkte nachbestellen, muss sein.
Und das Beste ist, ich glaube, hier sieht man es.
Ne, hier sieht man es nicht.
Genau, der wird dann immer glücklicher, je nachdem.
Man kann Achievements unlocken.
Es gibt auch Tutorial-Videos oder Tutorial-Anleitungen, how to Zähne putzen.
Gibt's da auch drin?
Aber es gibt, äh, Putz-Achievements.
Die kann man unlocken und direkt auf Facebook und Instagram sharen.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ich weiß, es hört sich an wie ein Witz.
Es ist kein Witz.
Äh, App-Achievements.
Oh, ich kann das Wort nicht schreiben.
Hier, hier, Trophies.
Sorry, Leute, Trophies.
Trophies kannst du unlocken.
Zum Beispiel Fresh-Breath-Journey.
White-Thing-Journey, was?
Was heißt das?
Gum? Gum? Hells?
Ach hier, Zahnfleisch oder sowas.
Kannst du anlocken, ja.
Da siehst du dann auch deine Challenge-Scores und deine Streaks.
Wie gut du das gebaut, irgendwie gute Zähne geputzt hast.
Hier, Rising-Streak.
Ne, Rinsing-Streak.
Personal Achievements.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Ähm...
Ja, und das ist tatsächlich so.
Ich muss euch aber sagen, ähm...
Ich hab mir das...
What the fuck?
Was hat ein Cookie-Klicker damit zu tun?
Ähm...
Ich hab die App einmal installiert
und danach wieder deinstalliert.
Ich hab die App, ich hab das nie verwendet.
Ich verwende die Zahnbürste auch nicht mehr.
Ich verwende wieder ne stinknormale, klassische, so...
Normale...
Wie nennt man die? So normale Rubbel?
Hin und her Rubbel?
Rum und hin und her Bürste?
Zahnbürste?
Die gefällt mir besser als die elektrische.
Aber damit kann man Geld verdienen, ja?
Mit ner Zahnbürste und Putz-Achievements.
Excellent.
Wir können das wirklich mal im Stream ausprobieren.
Man weiß, ein Trend ist vorbei,
wenn Unternehmen mit dem Trend anfangen. Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist das wirklich wahr.
Vor allem, dass jetzt die ganzen Leute versuchen,
irgendwie so auf coole,
coole Influencer-Gang zu machen, so.
Oder was ich noch schlimmer finde ist,
wenn dann irgendwelche
Unternehmen anfangen,
die letzten 20 Jahre
mehr
die Umwelt
verschmutzt, geschädigt, sonst was haben,
mit, wir haben jetzt unser
Green-Energy-Programm gestartet,
wir sind der Führer im Bereich Green,
was auch immer.
So ein blödes Gelaber immer, Alter.
So dachte ich mir so, oh Scheiße,
die Leute mögen uns nicht mehr.
Ähm...
Jetzt sind wir auf einmal furchtbar grün, ne?
Borderlands 3 fällt...
Was schreibt Herz93?
Borderlands 3 fällt mir eine absolute Influencer mit.
Ja, in Borderlands 3 war es ja noch okay.
Ich fand die Story von Borderlands 3
nicht gut, ja.
In Borderlands 3 war es noch okay.
Ne, was ich meine ist,
wenn du dann auf Twitter irgendwelche Ads siehst,
wo sie halt so diese...
Guck, ich sehe keine Werbung
auf Twitter.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich habe ja hier Adblock am Start.
Wenn sie dann halt so Werbung rausbauen,
so nach dem Motto, äh,
ich sag jetzt mal irgendwas ganz blödes,
so nach dem Motto, äh, gestylt wie Bibi,
oder irgendwie sowas,
dann läuft es auch mit den Instagram-Followern.
Irgendwie so dummes
Cringe-Marketing-Zeug,
was komplett keinen anspricht,
aber sie halt denken, oh, das ist 2020,
da sind Instagram-Follower angesagt,
deswegen schreiben wir was von Instagram-Follower
in unsere Werbung.
Stadia macht jetzt
mega viel Werbung auf YouTube.
Ich habe es gesehen.
Was machen eigentlich Stadia Games Liste?
Was haben die, wie viele gibt es Games?
Und ganz wichtig, was wir noch vorher
schauen müssen.
Magenta Gaming.
Was macht denn eigentlich
Magenta Gaming so?
Die Magenta DNA.
Oh, ja!
Also, wir haben hier natürlich
die absoluten Knaller.
Asterix und Obelix und Garfield Card
immer noch am Start.
Oh, habt ihr die Liste
mit den Spielen rausgenommen?
Die haben die, ah, ne, hier.
Hier ist die Liste mit den Spielen.
Also, gut.
Den Switcher gibt es ja nur
mittlerweile schon echt überall.
Oder das Spiel ist von
2015 oder so?
Was ist
Magenta Gaming?
Das ist das, was sich die Telekom überlegt hat,
vor allem so eine Default-Schrift.
Das ist, was die Telekom sich überlegt hat,
als alle großen Anbieter,
die dazu in der Lage sind, die auch ordentliche Spiele haben,
angefangen haben, Gamestreaming anzubieten,
hat die Telekom gesagt
und daraufhin haben sie dann
Magenta Gaming gemacht.
Das ist eine Unterwerbung von Shibo,
die auf Gamer
machen. Ja, genau sowas meine ich.
Okay, zeigt mal, ja, das muss ich mir angucken.
Das ist bestimmt Cringe hoch 10.
Oh, warte mal, ich habe gemutet.
Oh, das ist schlimm. Ich sehe schon,
das ist schon zum Fremdschirm.
What the fuck, Alter?
Oh, das tut weh.
Das tut weh.
Oh, das schmerzt.
Alter.
Das tut weh.
Ja, sowas meine ich.
Genau sowas meine ich.
Das ist,
wenn sie versuchen, so einen coolen Influencer-Shit
zu machen.
Das tut einfach nur weh.
Als ob man
von Shibo-Café zum Pro-Gamer
wird. Ey, es gibt auch
mittlerweile nur alles als Gaming,
als Gaming-Ausgabe.
Bis zum Gaming-Stuhl, bis zum Gaming-Tisch,
bis zu Gaming-Food,
bis zu Gaming, alles,
alles. Es gibt mittlerweile so fast
nix mehr, was nicht
Gaming-Ausgabe von gibt.
Kennst du schon
Medion Gaming? Die haben auch
sowas. Medion
Gaming
Stream. Warum?
Warum hat denn jeder sowas jetzt?
Cloud Gaming Medion.
Warum, warum, warum gibt's das
da, wo ist denn da die Existenzberechtigung?
Medion
Eraser.
Einfach mal Eraser.
Einfach mal so ein Wort reingebracht, das
damit überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Eine Top-Auswahl. Ja, wo sind
denn die Spiele? Spiele?
Äh.
Wo, wo,
wo sieht man denn da, was es für Spiele gibt?
50 plus. Ja, schön. Welche denn?
Skamas.
Als erstes sollten die sich vielleicht mal überlegen,
eine ordentliche Seite zu machen.
Okay, man sieht überhaupt nicht, was da dabei ist.
Bullshit, Alter.
Die Telekom, die gibt wenigstens
zu, dass sie keine gescheiten Games hat.
Ich meine, was ist das hier?
Ja, 5 Jahre altes Spiel.
Natürlich, wo wir schon
alle drauf gewartet haben,
Asterix und Obelix XXL2.
Wer wollte das schon nicht mal spielen?
Ähm.
Und sogar Asterix und Obelix XXL3.
Nicht nur XXL2,
die haben sogar XXL3. Stellt euch das mal vor.
Also das ist ja allein schon
das Abo ja mal
mehr als wert.
Ähm.
Irgendwelche Mobile Games.
World of Tanks.
Das ist nun wirklich mittlerweile überall drauf
und in jedem Store und auf jedem.
Also World of Tanks gibt es ja nix, wo es das nicht gibt.
Genauso wie
World of Warships. Den Kram gibt es auch nicht.
Irgendwelche komischen Mobile Games
Recycled.
Ähm. Was ist das denn?
Was zum?
Dann sind die Sachen doppelt.
Ah ne, das ist Evoland 1 und Evoland 2.
Da sind die ganzen
komischen Sniper Games drin.
Ein paar Sachen sind ganz okay.
So schlecht war das
gar nicht mal, aber.
Das hat schon ziemlich gesagt.
Kung Fu Rabbit.
Ja unbedingt.
Also hier, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Ich wollte schon ewig mal weiterspielen hier.
Aber nicht auf Magenta Gaming.
Und der Rest ist einfach nur.
Gefühlt
Free to Play Bullshit so.
Was genau möchte uns
die Telekom damit sagen?
Es ist wenigstens kostenlos.
Kostet wenigstens nix.
Zur Registrierung.
Benutzername.
Omega Lul.
Wir melden uns erstmal
und probieren das jetzt aus.
Passwort. Äh.
Login. Ach ne.
Moment.
Wie registriert man sich dann überhaupt?
Zur Registrierung.
Das ist bestimmt nur für Telekom.
Ja wahrscheinlich nur für Telekom.
Ja ich kann mich nicht registrieren.
Ach da muss ich mich mit dem Telekom Login anmelden.
Noch kein Telekom Login.
Telekom Login erstellen.
Ah. Easy.
Äh.
Ah. Nein.
Wie lautet denn der Beruf ihres Großvaters?
Oh das ist ne gute Frage Telekom.
Du wie die 8 Monate. Dankeschön.
Richtige Hackermans heute wieder.
Huge Subscription.
Ja was war mein Opa?
Was war mein Opa von Beruf?
Ich kann das Formular nicht ausfüllen.
Ich glaub mein Opa
war Influencer.
Was war mein Opa von Beruf?
Rentner.
Boomer. Ne der Opa war
Pre-Boomer.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung was mein Opa gelernt hat.
Elektrotechniker
oder sowas.
Gut wenns danach geht war mein Opa
vieles. Ich mein er war Soldat im 2. Weltkrieg.
Da war irgendwann mal ein Rentner.
Der hat ein Haus gebaut wo er bestimmt Mauern
gemacht hat. Ne aber ich glaub er
gelernt hatte irgendwas mit Elektrotechnik oder so.
Ähm.
Also sagen wir ja.
Anrede. Herr.
Ähm.
Peter.
Inder.
Benutzername.
Ähm. Was?
Jetzt brauch ich
auch noch die.
Okay wir hatten doch irgendwie so ne fake Google.
Wir hatten doch irgendwie so ne fake Google Account.
Gmail.
Ich hatte doch irgendwie so ne fake Google Account.
Wie war denn das? Omega Lull oder irgendwie sowas?
Oder Sebarro hatten wir nicht bei dir.
Genau wir machen 10-10-Minute-Mail.
Scheiß drauf.
10-10-Minute-Mail.
Ne. Was sind die richtige Seite davon?
Ach Sebarro hast du was?
Okay nice.
Das ist das drunter.
Ja das ist richtig.
Äh.
Bakao.
Okay.
Äh.
Okay also.
Das. Passwort.
Moment.
Okay.
Ja kann ich mit leben.
Excellent. Ähm.
Poggers.
Alter.
Anrede ist verpflichtend. Okay.
Herr. Moment.
Anzeige ist raus.
Ich kann mich nicht auswählen.
RIP.
Oh fuck Sebarro ich hab das Fenster zugeklickt.
Kannst du mir nochmal ne Nachricht schreiben?
Ähm. Mal gucken vielleicht geht das ja auch hier mit.
Erstmal Shit. Das machen wir.
Oh. Wir könnten die Telekom mal trollen.
Auf Twitter.
Da müssen wir aber das da unten dürfen wir nicht einblenden.
Weil sonst sehen die direkt das ich Fake Daten eingeben wollte.
Telekom Troll.
Okay. So erstmal ausprobieren ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Weiter.
Ha. Okay.
Da sind sie hier.
Excellent.
Okay.
Yes.
Aha.
Okay die muss ich mir kopieren.
Weil ansonsten vergesse ich die.
Weiter.
Magenta Gaming.
Excellent. Das will ich haben.
Unbedingt.
Ich will kein Newsletter.
Ah meinetwegen. Ich nehme auch ein Newsletter.
Ja.
Ja. Excellent.
Zurück.
Moment. Wie geht das jetzt?
Magenta Gaming. Ah. Okay.
Hey. Ich bin doch schon registriert.
Telekom.
Ich bin doch schon registriert.
Nein.
Was?
G-Baited.
Krasser G-Bait.
G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G
Sauerei, Alter.
Sauerei.
Okay.
Wie werde ich den Magenta Account wieder?
Peter.
Nein. Ich will den Account löschen.
Wie lösche ich den Account wieder?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich habe es angeblich.
Ach. Das ist nur der Newsletter oder was?
Dreckssäcke, Alter.
Okay.
Wie lösche ich den Account?
Wie lösche ich...
Was?
Ferimi.
Was ist das?
Hört sich an wie irgendwas, wo man Essen bestellen kann.
Wo kann ich was löschen?
Ich will den Account löschen.
Fax hinschicken.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ah, hier. Telekom.
Was informieren?
Was?
Okay. Abmelden.
Weg.
Peter Inder meldet sich.
Haha.
Alter.
Was ist mit euch los?
Fuck. Ich darf meinen Account nicht löschen.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Oder was?
Was ist los?
Die Musik passt.
So.
Jetzt informieren.
Ich schreibe mein Passwort richtig.
Das Passwort ist so simpel.
Geil.
Alter. Was ein G-Bait.
Ah. Ah.
Adblock.
Ihr habt recht, Leute.
Adblock ist es.
Oder auch nicht. Okay. Refresh.
Deletion.
Introduction.
XHTML.
Ne?
Ich darf mein Passwort nicht löschen.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Inkognito Mode.
Ups.
Naja. Okay.
Chrome. Im Chrome geht alles.
Inkognito Mode.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich mich erstmal einloggen, um mich dann wieder ausloggen zu können.
Das ist natürlich
Excellent.
Ihr Bestätigungscode. Ihr besteht.
Kündigungsbestätigung.
Ach ne. Magenta Gaming.
Also die G-Baiten mich hart.
Die G-Baiten mich wirklich.
Hallo. Hallo Chat.
Okay. Ja.
Warum kriege ich 30 Milliarden Bestätigungscodes geschickt?
Wahrscheinlich, weil der Chat sich versucht hat reinzuloggen.
Ja. Ähm.
So.
Jetzt habe ich mich eingeloggt, um mich.
Also ihr seht. Ich habe mich eingeloggt. Mein Passwort stimmt.
Ah.
Habe ich
Pornhub-Konto gesagt?
Hahaha. Was?
Ernsthaft?
Ja. Leak.
Gut.
Wunderbar. Also.
Jetzt ist mein Account gelöscht.
Mal gucken, wie das damit umgeht.
Wenn ich hier noch eingeloggt bin.
Guten Abend Peter Inder.
Wenn ich hier eingeloggt bin. Jetzt refreshe.
Das ist irgendwie nicht so ganz richtig.
Das ist irgendwie
nicht so ganz richtig.
Wahrscheinlich ist es voll kaputt.
Jetzt subscribe ich mal Magenta Gaming.
Mit meinem Account, der gelöscht ist.
Ah. Okay. Okay. Das geht nicht.
Okay. Okay. Aber. Aber.
Aber mein
Account kann ich noch verwalten.
Das ist hochgradig merkwürdig.
Was bei der Telekom da gerade ist.
Oh. Jetzt wurde ich rausgeworfen.
Mist.
Aber hier bin ich noch drinnen.
Exzellent.
Kann ich jetzt.
Kann ich jetzt
die E-Mail-Adresse erstellen für den Account, der gelöscht ist?
Kundencenter.
Ah. Nee. Okay.
Ich kann nichts mehr machen. Ich bin. Okay. Der Account
ist weg. Der Account ist
weg.
Ja. Gut.
Ja. Dann müssen wir
Medium Gaming ausprobieren, würde ich sagen.
Wenn Magenta...
Wenn...
Achso.
Okay. Please. Mehr Zeit.
Die Leute registrieren jetzt hier
den ganzen Scheiß, Alter.
Keck. Okay.
Registrieren wir uns hier nochmal her. Oh.
Das sieht ja mal absolut next level aus.
Das sieht ja mal
absolut next level aus. Hier.
Die Seite.
Danke, Sebao.
Okay. Also.
Peter. Inder.
Land.
Afghanistan.
E-Mail. Das da.
Registrieren.
Vielen Dank für deine Registrierung.
Okay. Und jetzt?
Was?
In den nächsten drei...
What?
Wie leben wir denn hier?
In... Moment. Also man muss sich das mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
In den nächsten drei
Werktagen.
Das bedeutet, da muss wirklich
noch irgendein Typ da sitzen und von Hand
Sachen anklicken.
Weil...
Ach.
Gott.
Deutschland 2020.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich fasse es nicht, Alter.
Willkommen im Neuland.
Ja, da muss
der Azubi erstmal ran.
Und E-Mails verschicken.
Ja, tatsächlich.
We love Java.
Geht fort, Leute. Ich mach das jetzt zu.
Kann man das... Kann man die E-Mail
Adresse wieder löschen?
Oder verfällt die einfach nach 10 Minuten
Die verfällt nach 10 Minuten
automatisch, ne?
Brigitte Redaktion.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Ich mach das jetzt zu.
Ich versuche im Chat noch komische Sachen zu machen, ne?
Aber eigentlich finde ich's ganz lustig
gerade.
Kann man die E-Mail Adresse auch so löschen?
Mobile Support haben wir auch.
Gut. Also.
Das hat nicht funktioniert mit den deutschen Streaming-Anbietern.
Schon mal wirklich wieder absolut
bezeichnet, dass sowas...
Oh, warte mal. Wo da vorn? Ach ja, Leute.
Hab ich euch schon erzählt.
Kannst du auf Get Another klicken, dann
verfällt die. Okay.
Leute, letzter Refresh.
Okay.
RIP.
E-Mail-Adresse ist weg.
Und die hier...
Machen wir jetzt zu. Wow.
Wonka S.
Hab ich euch eigentlich erzählt, was Vodafone hier zugeschrieben hat?
Ich lese euch...
Ich lese euch mal kurz vor, was Vodafone
zugeschrieben hat. Und zwar...
Also das war ja...
Das war ja gestern, als das Streaming
abgekackt ist um 11.14 Uhr.
Und ich mach mal kurz Twitter hier auf dem zweiten
Rechner auf, dass ich sehe.
Also.
Wir fassen mal zusammen. Die bisherigen
Ausreden von Vodafone.
Da müssen wir uns nur ein neues Textdokument machen.
Dass wir das mal alles
ähm...
historisch erfassen. Und zwar
die Ausreden von Vodafone
oder von Ausreden, waren
bisher erstens
WLAN-SSID doppelt.
Was kompletter
absoluter
der größte Bullshit ever ist.
Ähm...
Die sagen zum Beispiel,
also ich hab für 2,4 GHz
und 5 GHz WLAN die gleiche
SSID eingestellt und das würde Probleme
auf der Connect-Box machen.
Auf den Hinweis...
Vielleicht ist das bisschen laut jetzt.
Auf den Hinweis,
dass ich gar nicht das WLAN verwende
in der Connect-Box, meinte der
Techniker doch,
das ist wichtig,
weil sonst würden ja die Rechner
versuchen reinzukommen
und ins falsche reinzukommen und das würde
das Modem voll machen.
So oder so ähnlich
hat er mir das erklärt am Telefon.
Ich hab komplett
confused da gesessen.
Ich war
gerade mit einem Kollegen auf der Arbeit beim Mexikaner
beim Haftbefehl Mexikaner
das habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Der Haftbefehl Mexikaner.
Wir haben beim Haftbefehl Mexikaner gesessen
und da ruft mich der Vodafone Mann
an und erzählt mir sowas.
Ich hab dann da gesessen und so...
So, ich hab wirklich genau so da gesessen.
Ich hab's...
Ich wusste gar nicht was ich sagen sollte.
Hä? Was genau
höre ich hier gerade?
Gut, also das war das erste was Vodafone
versucht hat sich rauszureden.
Richtig, oi.
Massive.
So, das nächste was sie gesagt haben
ist...
Modem Neustart, das ist ja normal.
So.
Modem Neustart, allerdings
zwei Minuten Strom aus.
So.
Drittes ist
es gibt zurzeit
Probleme
mit der
Connect Box, aber die
sind behoben.
Also wieder
Modem Neustart, mindestens zwei Minuten
Strom aus.
Ähm...
So, jetzt überlege ich gerade noch was Neues dazu gekommen.
Hab ich da irgendwas vergessen
Leute? Ich hab's euch doch immer erzählt.
Ich hab's euch doch immer... Hab ich da irgendwas vergessen?
Ach ja, genau.
Genau. Danach...
Danach... Ich hab's ja ganz vergessen.
Modem Neustart ohne weitere Informationen
sollte ich danach machen.
So. Und jetzt kommt...
Jetzt kommt die neueste Ausrede
von Vodafone.
Ich lese es euch mal
vor. Also...
Ähm...
Also sie haben ja gesagt, ich soll mich melden.
Hier rauf, auf Twitter.
Da hab ich ihnen per PN geschrieben
MELD.
Und hab den Link zur Nachricht geschickt.
Okay. Und dann kam als Antwort
Hi, wenn das Problem... Also das kam am Samstag schon.
Hi.
Ähm...
Der Krieger hat ein geniales Video gemacht.
Ich hab schon ewig kein Video vom Krieger mehr geschickt...
äh... geguckt. Kannst ja mal den Link schicken.
Hi, wenn das Problem noch aktuell ist,
nenne mir bitte doch deine Handynummer.
Ich werde mich darum kümmern. Bitte versuche
als erstes einen Neustart des Routers.
Das ist das hier, was ich eingetragen hab.
So.
Dann hab ich dem geantwortet, also aktuell geht's.
Ich hab aber weder den Stream an, noch
Upload oder sonst irgendwas. Also...
ähm... Es wird sich wahrscheinlich erst
heute Abend zeigen, ob es wirklich wieder geht.
Router-Neustart mach ich gleich mal.
Du musst immer drauf eingehen, weil
ansonsten... äh... geht's nicht weiter.
Ich sag Bescheid und halte euch
auf dem Laufenden,
wenn die Probleme wieder losgehen.
Ähm...
So. Dann hab ich ja hier das geschrieben
an Vodafone. Das ist gestern
abgekacktes.
Und daraufhin hat Vodafone dann geschrieben,
irgendwie fünf Stunden
später oder so, äh...
Hallo, wir sind diesbezüglich
informiert und arbeiten gerade daran,
die Störung zu beheben.
Und wisst ihr, wer
geantwortet hat, Leute? Wisst ihr, wer geantwortet hat?
Wisst ihr, wer geantwortet hat?
Die Lieblings... äh...
Die kennt ihr auch noch. Die kennt ihr noch.
Mit der hatten wir schon öfters das Vergnügen.
Auch beim Unity Media Support
hatten wir schon das Vergnügen. Wer weiß noch, wie sie
heißt?
Wer weiß noch, wie sie heißt?
Die hat's anscheinend jetzt bis zum Vodafone
Support geschafft. Nicht Peter.
Nein! Ach, Leute.
Ist keiner mehr.
Christine hieß die.
Vielleicht erinnert sich doch der eine oder andere. Christine
hatten wir beim Vodafone... äh... beim Unity Media Support
öfters schon mal. Die hat's jetzt auch
zum Vodafone Support geschafft.
Ähm... ganz wahrscheinlich ist das Support-Team
von Unity Media und Vodafone mehr oder weniger
das gleiche. Also Christine hat geantwortet,
ähm... sie sind
dabei. So, und dann kam ein paar Minuten
später, zehn Minuten später,
nochmal...
äh... nochmal ne
ausführliche Nachricht. Ich vermute,
dass das ne Nachricht entweder
vom Support ist oder eventuell
vielleicht auch
von irgendeinem Social Media Mann.
Weil... oder Frau, da kennt man
an dem Kürzel nicht so genau. Weil...
die Antwort ist viel länger,
allerdings sagt sie auch nicht sonderlich viel aus.
So, und die neuste Ausrede
ist... Hallöchen, vielen
Dank für deine Nachricht. Tut mir leid
zu lesen, dass dein Stream beeinträchtigt ist.
Durch das Intro vermute
ich nämlich, dass das vielleicht irgendein Social Media
Mensch ist.
Ähm...
Es gibt da leider
im Moment eine Großstörung,
die deinen Anschluss beeinträchtigt.
Die Technik arbeitet
mit Hochdruck an der Behebung und das sollte
bald erledigt sein. Bitte hab noch
ein wenig Geduld.
Wenn alles wieder läuft, kannst du gerne wieder
schreiben.
Das läuft ja nicht...
Das ist jetzt eigentlich genau falsch rum.
Warum soll ich denn schreiben, wenn alles wieder läuft?
Ähm...
Dann können wir uns um eine entsprechende Gutschrift
kümmern. Ich wünsche dir einen
schönen Tag.
Ich glaube... Ich habe irgendwie
so im... Wie sagt man so? Im Urin...
Ne, so die Vermutung, das ist irgendein...
irgendein Social Media
Support-Mensch,
der quasi guckt auf...
Fuck, das lesen ja ein paar Leute auf Twitter,
wenn er das schreibt. Da müssen wir uns
jetzt mal drum kümmern. Also die sechste
Ausrede ist...
Großstörung im
Raum...
sagen wir mal Frankfurt. Im Raum Frankfurt
im Prinzip ist ja immer eine Gro...
Oder Hanau ist es ja in dem Sinne.
Ähm...
Frankfurt und so. Was aber ein totaler
Nachsinn ist, weil da ist immer irgendeine
Störung. Vodafone
ausreden.
So, das haben wir bis jetzt durch.
Aber man muss sagen, Leute,
bis heute,
wir sind jetzt eine Stunde
on und laut
Umfrage,
laut Umfrage
haben die meisten Leute drauf getippt,
dass
Vodafone innerhalb der ersten 60
Sekunden abkackt... äh 60 Minuten
abkackt.
Das ist nicht der Fall, das ist nicht
eingetreten. Also Chat
hat nicht recht.
Chat hat versagt.
Äh 60 Minuten, ja ihr wisst
doch, dass ich mit Einheiten nicht so
eng nehme.
Übrigens, man kann verschiedene Sachen, man kann
mehrere Sachen auswählen.
Wait for it.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist besser.
Ach ja...
Was? Störung?
Deutsche Telekom Karte, auch sowas haben die.
Oh.
Wow.
MonKS, das ist ja komplett...
Ist ja alles kaputt.
Frankfurt ist hier unten irgendwo.
Siehst du, da ist immer irgendwas kaputt
im Raum Frankfurt und in Hanau.
Raum Frankfurt und Hanau ist immer irgendwas kaputt.
Und warum ausgerechnet da?
Da ist der Main.
Da ist überhaupt nix.
Wo auf der Karte die Störung ist. Da ist nix.
Das ist irgendein Feld
gegenüber vom Main. Das hier ist der Main.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe.
Ja, das ist der Main und das ist irgendein Acker.
Irgendein Acker am Main, wo die Störung ist.
5G-Störung.
Ja, und das ist geil, ne?
Keine Störung und wir scrollen mal
in Deutschland raus.
Excellent. Keine Störung. Eindeutig.
So sieht
keine Störung aus.
Ja, wollen wir die Telekom
trollen mit
warum ich nicht mein richtiges Gender auswählen kann?
Eigentlich habe ich
keinen Bock auf so einen Scheiß.
Ich will bei diesem Thema
eigentlich überhaupt nicht mitmachen.
Okay.
Chat.
Twitter. Also.
Okay Chat.
Was schreiben wir denn?
Okay, was
schreiben wir denn?
Das ist eine Twitter-Nachricht.
Telekom erleben.
Ob wir was an Telekom erleben oder an Telekom Hilfe
Telekom Hilfe schreiben.
Okay.
Ich kann
hier gar nicht
mein richtiges
Gender auswählen.
Feels...
Ich wollte gerade schreiben, Feels-Selbstmordman,
aber das ist glaube ich zu hart, ey.
Das trägt an die Leute.
Feels-Batman.
Das klingt zu trollmäßig.
Lass die Twitch-Emotes weg.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist zu obvious, ja.
Da machen wir ein Emoji.
Und in Emoji rein.
Was? Was ist das?
Get Emoji.
Emoji.
Konfrontiere die mit einem? Was soll das?
Okay.
Ähm.
Erstmal bin ich traurig.
Doch, ich will, dass die...
Es soll schon so ein bisschen durchblicken, dass das ein Troll ist.
Das ist schon okay.
Oh!
Sendschuh an. Das ist richtig gut.
Leider ist es im Jahre 2020
immer noch nicht möglich, mein Geschlecht korrekt...
Das ist gut!
Das klingt so richtig nice.
Das klingt so...
Leider ist es auch im Jahr 2020
noch nicht möglich...
Ah, Moment. Nee, das müssen wir anders schreiben.
Ähm.
Für was war das?
Ich muss das so schreiben.
Leider konnte ich mir keinen Telekom-Account erstellen,
obwohl ich so gerne Magenta Gaming ausprobieren wollte.
Irgendwie sowas bescheuertes.
Ähm.
Vielleicht Keks. Ja, was denn sonst?
Leider konnte ich mir keinen Telekom-Account erstellen.
Und das, obwohl ich unbedingt
Magenta Gaming ausprobieren wollte.
Ups.
Ah, das ist doch doof.
Bei der Breitbandauswahl hängt auch die Genda-Auswahl bei euch hinterher.
Willst du das von deinem Max-FPS-Twitter machen?
Das ist eigentlich zu offensichtlich, ne?
Magenta Gaming.
Blablabla.
Das wird...
Das kann doch im Jahr 2020
nicht sein.
Fick.
Und dann nur noch den Screenshot drunter, oder?
Leider konnte ich mir keinen...
Leider konnte ich mir keinen Telekom-Account erstellen.
Und das, obwohl ich unbedingt...
Ähm.
Da ich mich so überhaupt nicht angesprochen fühle.
Irgendwie sowas.
So, mal gucken.
Wie kriegen wir jetzt das Bild darüber?
Moment, wie krieg ich jetzt das Bild hier rüber kopiert?
Ah! Telekom-Troll.
Wo ist...
Das stimmt, das könnte sein, dass die Leute übelst abgefuckt sind gleich.
Wenn ich sowas poste, Alter.
Wahrscheinlich ist besser, ich schreib das nicht.
Nicht wegen der Telekom, sondern...
Weil...
Das ja offensichtlich ein Trollversuch ist.
Und ihr wisst, wie leicht...
Heute alle getriggert sind.
Ne, ich mach das nicht.
Die Leute sind heute so schnell bei allem getriggert...
Ich mach denen einen Fake-Account und dann poste ich es offiziell im Stream.
Das ist auch irgendwie Big Brain.
Ne, ich mach das nicht.
Die Leute sind so schnell getriggert heute und ich hab keinen Bock,
dass ich mir die nächsten zwei Wochen irgendwelche Flames anhören muss auf Twitter.
Wo sich Leute behaupten, ich würde mich über die Situation lustig machen.
Wobei, mach ich ja auch irgendwo.
Und ich seh da überhaupt kein Problem.
Und dann muss ich ein Entschuldigungsvideo noch auf YouTube hochladen.
Dann muss ich dann weinen im Entschuldigungsvideo.
Nein, Leute, das war überhaupt nicht so geplant.
Und ihr seid doch die Wichtigsten in meinem Leben.
Gibt Klicks, Max.
Klickt nach gutem Content.
Dann kommt ein Video von Mirella.
Wer ist Mirella?
Du kannst das schön überzeugen.
Ich überleg mir mal.
Vielleicht fällt mir doch irgendwas Gutes ein.
Ich poste ja gerne so Sachen, wenn sie halt
offensichtlich sind, aber nicht zu offensichtlich.
Das ist gut. Elevencore, das machen wir.
Das machen wir.
Telekom Troll.
Äh, meint.
At Telekom
hilft.
Get Emoji, da brauchen wir passende Emoji für.
Wir müssen das meint.
Meint, meint, meint.
Wir müssen noch hier.
Wir müssen das noch bearbeiten.
Edit.
Roter Kreis.
Safe. Perfekt.
Kreis.
Stimmt. Wahnsinnskreis.
Ja, ich geb's zu.
Mal gucken, was da als Antwort kommt.
Kannst nicht mit Windows?
Doch, kann ich.
Rotes Quadrat.
So, mal gucken.
Okay, mal gucken, ob die Telekom darauf antwortet.
Moment.
Ich wollte eigentlich den Twitter post.
Mal gucken, ob die Telekom darauf reagiert, ey.
Das ist so unglaublich dämlich schon.
Mal schauen, ob da irgendwas kommt.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, genau. Ich hab grad erklärt, warum mein Stream schlecht ist.
Hab ich ausführlich genug erklärt, oder?
Warum das Stream schlecht ist.
Und das Schlimmste ist, Leute. Wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste ist?
Ich zähl mal kurz meine Emotes,
die ich, ähm, einblenden könnte.
Also, wartet mal, wartet mal.
Ich geh mal kurz auf meinen Twitch-Account
und dann sag ich euch, wie viele Emote-Slots ich hab.
und wie viele Emote-Slots ungenutzt sind.
Ähm, Creator-Dashboard.
Aktuell sind wir übrigens wieder bei...
Wollt ihr wissen, wie viele Abonnenten es gerade sind?
Oder ist euch das ziemlich, äh...
Wollt ihr das wissen?
45? Nee.
Äh, es sind gerade...
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Ich, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich weiß, was wir machen. Leute, stopp.
Wir machen, wir machen eine Umfrage.
Wir machen eine Umfrage.
Ähm...
Bei
wie vielen Subs sind wir?
Ähm...
Also, äh, nee.
Wir können keine Umfrage machen.
Nee, machen wir anders. Machen wir anders.
Also, ähm, wer
richtig liegt,
also ich, ich poste gleich, ich poste
gleich im Chat hier.
Ich poste das hier gleich im Chat.
So, oder irgendwie sowas.
So.
Und dann müsst ihr eine Zahl sagen.
Beginnend ab 0.
Excellent.
Und...
Wer richtig liegt,
kann man nicht
den Nightbot nutzen. Doch, wahrscheinlich.
Mal gucken. Ähm...
Kannst ja mal gucken,
ob du so was eingerichtet kriegst.
So, und wer richtig liegt,
wer richtig liegt,
kriegt einen Sub.
Gegiftet.
Es ist alles mitgezählt.
Subgift oder gifted subs
macht keinen Unterschied.
Und, ähm, was machen wir für die Leute,
die schon einen Sub haben?
Ähm...
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Wenn ihr schon einen Sub habt,
ähm...
Was könnte man da machen?
Ja, der Tainser geht wieder ab.
Hilfe. Dankeschön. Fünf Stück.
Huge. Der hat schon 36 Abos
verschenkt.
Sebarro, kriegst du das hin mit dem Nightbot?
Das wäre ultra nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Ähm... Dankeschön für die Subs.
Excellent. Wahnsinn.
Der IQ des Chat platzt heute wieder.
Wahnsinn.
Wir hatten was gekriegt.
Max Jakob 1.
Hansa 81.
Der Matt 9908.
Nano 5x und Antti.
Haben alle einen Sub von Tainser
geschenkt bekommen.
Wahnsinn.
Kann ein Giveaway starten?
Ja, Sebarro, ist das dann das?
Probier es einfach mal aus.
Also, Leute,
die schon Subs sind,
was kriegen die?
Ich habe keine Idee, ehrlich gesagt.
Was kriegen die Leute,
die Subzahlen richtig erraten und schon Subs sind?
Habt ihr eine gute Idee?
Die kriegen...
Ja klar, die kriegen das nächst höhere Tier...
Tier...
...gegiftet, falls das geht.
Falls das geht.
Ne, Mod geht nicht.
Mod muss ich mir die Leute aussuchen.
Ich habe 5 Subs...
Echt? Habe ich vergessen vorzulesen?
Oh, Moment.
Der Tainser, sehe ich hier gerade.
RealRenax hat einen gegiftet bekommen.
Nochmal, excellent.
Dankeschön. So, und dann noch welche?
Tatsächlich, noch mehr.
Es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf heute.
Was ist denn hier los?
Und vor allem, wo ist der Hype-Train hin?
Der Scam-Train muss doch schon längst am Start sein.
Schon längst am Start sein, ja.
Ähm...
Ha.
So, wer hat welche gekriegt hier?
Der Yannick0000, NicoCR,
SiriusMaxx unter Bonbon.
Heute geht es aber
echt zur Sache.
Vegas
Stufe 1.
Richtige Hacker, HighIQ-Leute heute.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay, also.
Scheiß drauf, wir probieren es jetzt.
Also, ich refreshe.
Gleich streibe ich Start im Chat.
Und wer es richtig errät,
kriegt einen Sub gegiftet. Wer schon einen Sub hat,
falls das geht,
behalte ich mir mal vor, weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das funktioniert,
der kriegt von mir einen Sub gegiftet,
die nächst höhere Stufe.
Und wisst ihr, was ihr dann davon habt?
Nix.
Weil ich keine Emotes habe.
Keine Tier-Emotes.
Wie viele freie Emote-Slots?
Ja, das verrate ich nicht.
Wenn ich die freien Emote-Slots verrate,
dann weiß man schon ungefähr, was das für Sub sind.
Wir raten erstmal die Sub-Zahl.
Okay, Leute.
Auf geht's. Moment.
Moment, warte. Der Sebarro sagt warte.
Okay.
Dann warten wir, bis der Sebarro sagt okay.
Wenn der Sebarro sagt okay, ist okay.
Übrigens, falls mehrere Leute richtig liegen,
kriegen alle einen Sub,
die richtig liegen.
Alle, es kriegen alle einen Sub, die richtig liegen,
es sei denn, es sind mehr als fünf.
Weil ich habe jetzt keinen Bock,
der die Fälle,
das alles rauszuhalten.
Aber fünf wird eh schwierig,
weil die Zahl ist,
ich glaube, da tippen nicht so viele drauf.
Genau, Sebarro testen wir es.
Sebarro, teste einfach in Ruhe.
Ähm.
Und wir machen mal weiter.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch ein paar
Questions hier gab.
Aber jetzt habe ich es vorgelesen.
Das ist Mirella.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das aufmachen soll.
Wer ist Mirella?
Okay, es ist ein YouTube-Link.
Das kann schon mal nicht...
Kenne ich nicht.
Wer ist das?
538k?
Habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm.
Oder geht es schon los?
Irgendwie klappt das nicht.
Die Dislikes?
Wieso?
Ach du Scheiße.
Jetzt war es so schlimm wie Diablo im Mobile-Trailer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was da gerade im Chat abgeht.
Ja, aber die Antwort von Lonix stimmt nicht.
Die Antwort von Lonix stimmt nicht.
Auch wenn er angeblich gewonnen hat.
Aber die ist falsch.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt manuell.
Also, Leute.
Also, ich poste jetzt hier
start, start, start in den Chat
und ab da müsst ihr raten,
wie viele Subs ich habe.
Und wer doppelt postet, ist disqualifiziert.
Oh, Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Ich muss meine Chat-History...
Das ist ja viel komplizierter, als ich mir das gedacht habe.
Ich muss in meiner Chat-History einstellen.
Sonst sind die Antworten...
Ah, ne.
Leute, wir machen das anders.
Hier, guckt mal. Ich habe doch hier mal ein geiles Tool.
Ihr müsst AdWubLoss.de machen.
Ihr müsst einfach vorschreiben.
Dann müsste das funktionieren, eigentlich.
Ich habe doch hier mal ein exzellent,
exzellent Tool.
Leute, scheiß drauf. Wir probieren das jetzt einfach.
Schreibt in Chat,
sobald ich start sage,
ich probiere bloß noch gerade mal meine
meine History mehr einzutun.
Das muss doch gehen.
Mod-Ansicht, Chat-Einstellungen.
Bin ich jetzt total bescheuert?
Hier.
Also.
History, Chat.
Mal kurz Chat.
Chat, Chat.
Aktion.
Warum ist das
FFZ-Menü so
unübersichtlich?
Lipziger, Stufe 1. Dankeschön.
Für den Huge Sub.
Wie kann man den FFZ einstellen?
FFZ History Size.
Das geht noch nicht los.
Der Chat dreht wieder voll am Rad.
Länge des Chatverlaufs.
Hier. Okay. 5000.
Das muss jetzt reichen.
Länge des Chatverlaufs
ist 5000.
Okay, Leute.
Chat.
5000. Also, auf geht's.
Leute. Jetzt.
Wie viel Subs sind es aktuell?
Ach du Große.
Okay.
10 Sekunden noch.
10, 9, 8,
7,
6,
5, 4,
3, 2,
1, 0.
So, fertig.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Die korrekte Zahl wäre gewesen.
195.
Hat das jemand?
Dennis SCC hat's.
Nur Dennis SCC.
Und Dennis SCC ist auch kein Sub.
Na, wie gut das passt.
Pock.
Moment.
Subgift muss ich erst mal einstellen.
Äh. Abo verschenken.
Wenn das jetzt so richtig funktioniert.
Abo verschenken.
Stufe 1.
Bezahlen mit Paypal.
Jawohl.
Kauf abschließen.
Äh. Soll das eigentlich funktionieren?
Da ist er.
Bam.
Huge.
Ja, wo bloß?
Dankeschön für den verschenkten Sub.
Wunderbar. Okay.
Jetzt haben wir mal ein erstes, das erste
Giveaway.
Du machst gut.
Ah, ja, ja.
Und übrigens, du hast Recht im Discord gehabt.
Keine echten, keine echten Bildchen.
Ja.
Okay, also Axi fragt gerade.
Ist eine interessante Frage.
Kann ich mal kurz beantworten.
Ich brauche einen Rat.
Ich will ESP-IDF, heißt das, benutzen.
Aber auch Plattform I.O.
Mit Firebase ESP...
Was zum Teufel ist denn Firebase ESP32?
Kenn ich gar nicht.
Ich kenn Firebeetle ESP32.
Wie kann man das am besten kombinieren?
Ähm.
Da musst du überhaupt nichts Großartiges für machen.
Plattform I.O. hat
direkt
im Projekt
erstellen.
Ach, für Mesh-Netzwerke.
Ach so, boah, nee. Keine Ahnung. Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Weil zu EDF wollte ich sagen,
Plattform I.O. hat direkt im Assistent zum erstellen
vom Projekt, kannst du das
auswählen, dass du ESP-IDF
verwenden willst. Nein, für Mesh-Netzwerke weiß
ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Hast du Tipps für das Fachgespräch?
Du meinst, machst du gerade Ausbildung?
Was machst du für eine Ausbildung?
Der Kupfermann?
Ich kann dir nochmal erzählen, wie das bei mir gelaufen ist.
Ich hab's da schon 75.000 Mal
erzählt gefühlt, aber ich find die
Story ist so
bescheuert, ja, mit der IHK, dass man
das ruhig, ruhig öfters
erzählen kann. Übrigens, bis jetzt ist das Ganze noch nicht
abgekackt.
Also wer noch nicht, wer noch nicht die
Ehre hatte mit der IHK,
das sind die Jungs und Mädels.
Oh, Corona, die haben Corona-Informationen.
Excellent.
Anwendungsentwicklung
macht er, okay.
Also, das sind die hier.
Und als ich meine
Ausbildung gemacht hab, ich hab ja mal
irgendwann Fachinformatik
Systemintegration gelernt.
2010 war das.
Oder?
Ne, 2007.
2010.
2007 hab ich das gemacht.
Also ist schon ein bisschen
her, ja. Und ich war auch schon
relativ alt, muss man sagen.
Guck mal Leute, ich bin 1984 geboren.
Ich
bin jetzt dann
demnächst 36.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Richtig Boomer.
Und ich hab 2007 dann die Ausbildung
gemacht. Das heißt, dann war ich
2007, wie alt war
ich denn da? 25 oder so?
Ne, Quatsch.
Quickmuffs 23
war ich da. Ach, das geht doch eigentlich.
Oder? Heutzutage mit 23 ist man
doch eigentlich noch
so eigentlich normal.
Ich mein, die meisten fangen ihre Ausbildung irgendwie mit 16, 17
oder so an, wenn sie den Gehaltsschulabschluss haben.
Aber 23 ist doch
dann eigentlich voll normal. Ne, 16,
17 hast du keinen Gehaltsschulabschluss, oder?
Doch, so in dem Dreh wahrscheinlich. Ist auch wurscht.
Zumindest,
das hab ich damals gelernt, hat jetzt ja nicht mehr,
was ich jetzt auf der Arbeit mache, hat ja hiermit jetzt nicht mehr allzu
viel zu tun. Zumindest um
vielleicht mal für die Leute, die jetzt ihre Abschlussprüfung
machen, nochmal das einmal
jetzt noch zum Besten zu geben. Ich hab's ja schon oft
erzählt. Also bei mir lief das mit der Abschlussprüfung
folgendermaßen. Ich hatte meinen Termin
irgendwann im August.
Hi Happen, so sieht's aus. Ja.
So sieht's aus. Feels old, man.
Ähm...
Hast du davor schon eine Ausbildung? Ja, ich hab davor
was anderes gemacht.
Da will ich aber nichts zu erzählen, weil es komplett
äh...
nicht meins war und
voll für den Arsch eigentlich, was ich davor gemacht hab.
So, also, ähm...
Ich hatte meinen Termin zur Abschlussprüfung
ähm...
und
die war, es war irgendwann, irgendwann
nachmittags im August in der Börse.
Also wer in Frankfurt
seine Ausbildung macht, der wird früher
oder später vielleicht das Glück
haben, dass er auch zur Börse muss.
Die IHK macht gerne Abschlussprüfung in der Börse.
Was mit Holz?
Nein, ich hab... Nein.
Nichts mit Holz. Mit Holz wollte
mich das Arbeitsamt damals zu überreden, dass
ich was mit Holz mache.
Zumindest ich hab meinen Termin.
Und an dem Tag,
wo meine Prüfung war,
ich blende mal was ein, weil ich ja weiß, dass die
durchschnittliche Aufmerksamkeitsdauer heute
nicht mehr so hoch ist. Also,
ich hab den Termin für meine Abschlussprüfung
gehabt an dem Tag, wo meine Abschlussprüfung
war bei der IHK.
Also sprich, an dem einen Tag im August.
Da hat morgens mein Telefon
geklingelt. Also ich hab die, äh...
Ich hab die schriftliche Prüfung, so alles schon
geschrieben. Es geht um die mündliche, um die
mündliche, äh...
Prüfung.
So. Und...
An dem Tag hat eines morgens
dann mein Telefon geklingelt.
Und da bin ich dran gegangen und so, ja...
So. Hab ich deinen Namen gesagt, so.
Und da war, da war, äh...
eine Frau von der IHK dran.
Und die hat gesagt, äh...
Herr Max,
Sie sind durchgefallen bei der Prüfung.
Hab ich gesagt, das kann nicht sein.
Meine Prüfung ist heute erst
um 14 Uhr. Ich kann da gar nicht
durchgefallen sein.
Ähm...
Ich dachte, das funktioniert.
Ich dachte, die hat den falschen Angriff, was auch immer.
So. Und dann sagte sie so, ja...
Ähm... Sie haben ihre Abschluss...
Ihre Projektdokumentation nicht abgegeben.
Und deswegen
hat sie da das Prüfungskomitee
durchfallen lassen.
Hab ich gesagt, das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Ich hab die, ich hab die Abschlussdokumentation
da hochgeladen.
Ähm... Ich hab sogar noch die Bestätigungs-
E-Mail von euch. Und außerdem...
Warum fällt euch das heute
ein? An diesem Tag?
Na gut. Ähm... Dann hat sie gesagt,
oh ja, dann ist das was anderes.
Ähm... Ja, ob ich hier irgendwie
noch die Bestätigungs-E-Mail
schicken kann, dass
ich's hochgeladen hab.
Ja, das ist jetzt schwierig. Die hab ich auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin daheim, weil ich fahr
heute Mittag direkt zur Prüfung.
Ähm... Aber ich guck mal. So.
Und dann hab ich mich damals auf abenteuerlichste
Art und Weise... Ich glaub,
der Felix... Ich glaub, der Felix war
sogar an meinem Notebook noch dann irgendwann dran.
Hat sich versucht einzuloggen mit mir am Telefon.
Wir haben uns dann irgendwie SSH tunnelt
und X-Forwardet. Und ich musste dann mir dann
nen Lotus Notes über SSH
X-Forwarding über drei Sachen
aufbauen, dass ich daheim meine E-Mails
angucken kann mit VPN. Ähm...
Mit VPN und
Remote arbeiten hatten wir es 2007 noch
nicht, logischerweise.
Lotus Notes, Alter. So, dann hab ich
die E-Mail gefunden, hab ich der Frau von der IHK
geschickt. Und dann meint sie so,
oh ja, gut, dann ähm...
Dann soll ich ganz normal zur Prüfung kommen. Und...
Und ob ich das nochmal
ausdrucken könnte, weil
die haben das jetzt ja nicht.
Okay, das geht schon...
Das geht schon gut los.
Also hab ich den ganzen
Kram nochmal ausgedruckt.
Mir hätte es ihn auch weiterleiten können
per PDF, aber das war zu advanced.
Ja. So, hab ich den ganzen Kram
noch dreimal ausgedruckt für die drei Prüfer.
Mach da doch ein Video
zu. Hab ich das nicht sogar schon mal...
Aber das ist ne gute Idee.
Schreib ich mir grad mal auf.
Ähm, ja.
Brauchen wir noch hier ein Video...
Video... Videoideen...
Abschlussprüfung.
So.
So, also hab ich den Kram ausgedruckt.
Bin mittags zur Börse gefahren,
nach Frankfurt. Warum dann nicht gleich
als Ausbildung verlinken? Das ist ne gute Idee.
So, und...
Dann wurde ich
ganz normal aufgerufen. Sonst was bin ich
reingegangen, hab meine Abschlusspräsentation gehalten.
Hab denen die...
die Dokumentation in die Hand gedrückt.
Und man muss sagen,
das war wirklich...
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Das war, glaub ich, die einfachste Abschlussprüfung,
die man...
die man je haben kann. Weil die hatten,
bevor ich da angerückt bin,
keinen blassen Schimmer, um was mein
Projekt geht.
Die hatten also wirklich überhaupt
keinen Plan.
Das erste Mal, dass die was von meinem Projekt
gehört haben, war halt, als ich in diesen Raum
reingegangen bin.
Und die haben mich ja... genau, die haben mich ja nochmal 15 Minuten
rausgeschickt, dass sie sich das durchlesen können.
So, und die hatten halt
absolut keinen Plan von der ganzen Geschichte.
Ähm, sie haben's halt...
die hatten auch keine Chance vor. Aber sie konnten mich ja nicht durchfallen lassen,
weil ich hab die Abschlussprüfung ja abgegeben.
Äh, die... die Dokumentation
ja abgegeben. Und...
Es ist dann rausgekommen,
der IHK-Server ist gecrashed.
Eine halbe Minute, nachdem
ich meine Sachen hochgeladen hab,
und hatte Datenverlust.
Und deswegen war meine Abschlussdokumentation
nicht da.
Also sprich, der IHK-Webserver
ist gecrashed. Er hat's gerade noch
geschafft, mir eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail
zu schicken, und danach ist er
gecrashed. Und hat meine
Abschlussdokumentation verloren.
Also so unfähig muss der erstmal sein.
Zumindest hab ich dann die...
ähm, hab ich dann meine
Prüfung, meine, äh, na,
Vortrag da gehalten.
Meine Abschlusspräsentation gehalten.
Und das lief richtig gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das ging. Ich glaub, 15 Minuten
muss man da was erzählen. Das hat ganz gut hingehauen.
Ich bin fast... fast auf den Punkt.
Und normalerweise, und das war auch
grad die Frage im Chat, normalerweise
gibt's danach ja dann noch so ein...
eine Frage-und-Antwort-
Fachgespräch-Runde.
Und je nachdem,
was du da für Prüfer sitzen hast,
hab ich schon öfters gehört, dass
da relativ doofe Fragen kommen können.
Je nachdem, mit was sich die Prüfer halt auskennen.
Fast nicht. Mein Fachgespräch hat
dadurch, dass die keine Ahnung hatten,
was ich gemacht habe und es sich im Vorfeld nicht angucken
konnten, hat nicht stattgefunden.
Da mein Fachgespräch lief ungefähr
so. Also ich war fertig mit meiner Präsentation.
Sagt so, ähm,
fertig, so, wenn's jetzt noch Fragen gibt,
dann, ähm, ich bin jetzt fertig.
Und da hat er gesagt, ja,
also, Herr Max, äh,
ich hätte, ich hätte da noch eine Frage.
Hat das denn funktioniert am Ende? Hab ich gesagt, ja, gut.
Funktioniert. Ja,
okay. Bestanden.
Fertig. Das war's.
Das war mein Fachgespräch.
Easy. Easy as fuck,
Alter.
Aber ehrlich gesagt,
das hab ich auch verdient, insofern,
dass sie mich geschockt haben, mit sie sind durchgefallen.
Überlegt euch das mal. Ihr wart,
ihr, ihr, ihr werdet durch ein
Telefon geweckt morgens.
An einem Tag, wo ihr eure Abschlussprüfung
habt. Und da ruft
einer von den IHK'ern und sagt, ihr seid durchgefallen.
Da, da denkt ihr erstmal echt so,
äh, was?
Also, was?
Also, insofern finde ich, hab ich
das, hab ich das verdient, dass es da
nicht so übertrieben haben.
Ja, und soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Erstmal Herzinfarkt. Ja,
so ein bisschen in der Richtung. Mir war schon
klar, dass da irgendwas schiefgelaufen sein muss, dass es, dass es
gar nicht sein kann. Ähm,
ja, das wär's
jetzt gewesen, wenn die gesagt hätten, so nach dem Motto,
ach ja, dann machen sie halt ein halbes Jahr länger.
Das, das wär's jetzt noch gewesen.
Ähm,
ja, aber soll ich euch,
soll ich, soll ich euch mal was,
was verraten? Kann ich jetzt ja machen, ist ja,
ist ja verjährt.
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Also, der hat mich zwar
gefragt, ob alles funktioniert hat,
aber, ich hab ihm gesagt,
ja, es hat alles funktioniert, aber
stimmt gar nicht.
Es hat weder funktioniert,
noch hat es nicht funktioniert.
Oh, da haben wir die, die passende
Musik dazu. Jutsch.
Ähm, und zwar,
ich hab mein Abschlussprojekt
gar nicht gemacht.
Ich hab mein Abschlussprojekt
überhaupt nie gemacht.
Ich, das einzige, was ich gemacht hab,
ist, ich hab eine
Dokumentation geschrieben über ein fiktives Abschlussprojekt.
Die war schon
von mir. Ja, also Dokumentation
ist nicht so, dass ich die gefakt hätte oder so.
Aber das Projekt hab ich nicht gemacht.
Es war alles von vorne bis
hinten fake, was da drin gestanden hat.
Ähm,
warum?
Ja, warum ist ganz einfach.
Ähm,
ich wollte ja ein Projekt machen, aber das
konnte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt in der Firma
dann nicht mehr machen, beziehungsweise hat es sich nicht gelohnt,
weil es kein Mensch mehr gebraucht hat.
Und deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht, okay, bevor ich mich
jetzt da wirklich hinsetze, und wo wir wieder bei dem
Thema sind, dass ich halt ein fauler Sack bin, da hatten wir's
am Anfang von, bevor ich mich da jetzt hinsetze,
ähm,
und
irgendwas
baue, was komplett,
aber wirklich komplett überflüssig ist,
und sogar eher umgedreht ist, gar keiner
haben will, hab ich gesagt, okay,
nimmst dir einfach Zeit, schreibst eine ordentliche
Dokumentation und gut ist.
Vielleicht wird Max geswartet, ja.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Gleich
kommt die IAK durchs Fenster abgeseilt, ja.
Ich glaub, das interessiert
kein Mensch mehr.
Das interessiert heute keinen mehr.
Und mal davon abgesehen,
es ist ja auch insofern nicht verboten.
Da steht ja nirgendwo explizit, dass du
das Projekt machen musst.
Wenn du das so verkaufen kannst,
dass du das Projekt gemacht hast,
deine Abschlussprüfung bestehst,
deine Präsentation bestehst
über ein Projekt, was du nicht gemacht hast,
die Dokumentation schreibst über ein Projekt,
was du nicht gemacht hast, ähm,
und alles so gut, dass es
akzeptiert wird, so, okay.
Worum ging es in diesem Projekt?
Ich hab nen VPN gebaut.
Äh, moin, hat jemand eine Idee,
was man mit einem Webspace machen kann,
den man nicht braucht?
Äh, kündigen.
Dann bezahlst du kein Geld mehr
für die Webspace.
Tibelius schreibt,
kam mir in dem Video damals irgendwie
immer so vor, als wärst du eher so strebermäßig
dabei gewesen,
hab mir das damals immer als
Motivation rangezogen, wenn's um Klausuren
ging. Hey, wenn's geholfen hat, ist doch gut.
Nee,
ich war nie strebermäßig unterwegs,
was, ähm,
Arbeitseinsatz, äh,
in der Schule und so anbelangt, nie.
Ich hab wirklich nur das gemacht, was notwendig
ist. Ich mein,
in der Berufsschule später war halt easy
as fuck. In der Berufsschule hatte ich nur Einser,
weil Berufsschule auch wirklich
das einfachste auf der Welt ist.
Easy, easy.
Ich hatte sogar,
stellt euch das mal vor, ich hatte sogar einen Sportner 1,
in der Berufsschule,
weil ich an keinem Tag gefehlt hab.
Das hat gereicht.
Aber dann hat jeder ne Eins gekriegt.
Das war voll total bescheuert.
Naja, ähm,
also ich glaube,
also ich will jetzt nicht übertreiben,
weil ich weiß es nicht mehr genau,
aber ich glaube, ich hatte nen Durchschnitt
von, keine Ahnung, 1,4 oder sowas,
ähm, in, in,
im Abschlusszeugnis,
das war wirklich, Berufsschule
war wirklich lächerlich einfach.
Euer Sportlehrer nennt das
ein bisschen ernster, okay.
Du hast doch sogar erzählt, dass du immer ausgerechnet
hast, dass du ne 4 hattest und an PC durftest.
Richtig, ja.
Wie die Leute das hier wissen.
Ja, es ist so, ich hab wirklich immer nur
das Mindeste gemacht in der Schule,
was notwendig war.
So, und im Nachhinein
muss ich sagen, war das auch die richtige Entscheidung.
Weil, du lernst so viel
Schwachsinn in der Schule,
was einfach komplett
auch an deinen Interessen vorbei geht
und auch an dem, was du später machen willst,
oder machen wirst,
ob du das machen kannst, was du machen willst,
oder was anderes, das ist zum größten Teil
komplett, komplett verschenkt, ja.
Ob ich jetzt irgendwie
Zellmembranen in Biologie
malen kann oder nicht, heute guck ich auf Wikipedia,
wenn ich wisse, wie sowas aussieht.
Das Video vom Krieger, also, stimmt,
wir wollen noch das Video vom Krieger gucken, zeig mal her.
Wechsel von Unity Media.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt nochmal an.
Ich hab schon ewig kein Video vom Krieger
mehr geguckt.
Ist da auch der
Chopper Gunner wieder am Start?
So.
Schau mal her.
11.000 Views.
Klar lebt der doch, der streamt sogar
auf Twitch.
Der streamt sogar auf Twitch.
Wir haben uns sogar schon ein paar mal gegenseitig gehostet.
Also, der hat immer so
500,
600 Zuschauer oder so.
Okay, also schauen wir mal an, was hat er denn?
Das Intro immer noch dasselbe
wie vor einem Jahrzehnt. Das stimmt, aber
wenigstens hat er ein Intro.
Ich mach ja mein Intro gar nicht mehr rein.
Ich mach ja auch kleine Videos.
Und herzlich willkommen zu diesem Wiederkommen.
Oh, er erzählt ja nur. Zu ein bisschen Realtalk
aus der Bude.
Keine Ahnung. Liebe Freunde, ich war
früher Partner, beziehungsweise, was heißt Partner?
Ich war Businesskunde bei
Unity Media.
Ja.
Und dieses Unternehmen wurde
aufgekauft von Vodafone.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, als ich bei Unity Media
Businesskunde war, habe ich
knapp 100 Euro gezahlt.
Er kommt bestimmt direkt aus dem Swimmingpool gerade.
Für eine
400er Leitung. Also sprich,
ich hatte einen Upload von 400.000,
einen Download von 400.000
und hatte einen Download von
20.000.
Es gab sehr selten.
Jetzt muss ich pingelig sein.
Wo ist die
Einheit?
Es gab wirklich sehr selten Ausfälle.
400 was?
Hey, schönen guten Tag. Ich bin Commander Krieger.
Oh, schönen guten Tag, Herr Commander Krieger.
Was können wir für Sie tun?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe hier gerade ein paar Probleme. Können Sie mir helfen?
Natürlich gerne.
Und mir wurde auch eigentlich immer recht schnell geholfen.
So.
Okay, als Businesskunde kann es schon sein.
Unity
Media wurde verkauft
an Vodafone.
Ja.
Und ich habe mir gedacht...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Ich gehe immer noch davon aus,
dass es eigentlich unter der Haube nicht viel
gemacht hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das
gedacht habe. Unity Media war vorher auch schon kacke.
... einem neuen Unternehmen an und sagst,
hey, schönen guten Tag, du bist Commander Krieger.
Vielleicht kann man da irgendwelche neuen Business
Deals aushandeln.
Das erste, und das meine
ich jetzt gar nicht böse, bei mir wäre die Frage
genau das gleiche. Das erste wäre
die Frage, wer ist Commander
Krieger? Das ist genauso, wie wenn
ich da anrufen würde und sagen,
hallo, hier ist MaxFPS.
Dann würde ich sagen, hallo, wer
heißt da?
Ja, hier Commander Krieger.
Ich habe eine Businessleitung
bei Ihrem
aufgekauften Unternehmen, Unity Media.
Wie sieht denn das jetzt aus?
Konditionsmäßig.
Ja, Herr Krieger, da haben wir
natürlich hervorragende Neuigkeiten.
Sie haben bisher eine
400er Leitung.
Vergiss es, das ist Schmutz.
Wir haben eine 1000er Leitung.
Das heißt, Sie haben einen Download
von 1000.
Und einen Upload von
50.
Das Verhältnis
ist schon geil, oder?
1000 zu 50.
Dass die so einen Scheiß überhaupt verkaufen.
Das kostet nur die Hälfte für Sie.
Und nicht nur für Sie, sondern auch
für jeden Ficker da draußen.
Ist das nicht schön?
Das heißt,
ich persönlich kann
jetzt einfach hingehen und kann sagen,
ich möchte die 1000er Leitung haben.
Ich zahle weniger.
Ich bleibe weiter Businesskunde.
Und du kriegst erstmal Dual Stack Lite.
Und
ich kriege eine bessere Leitung.
Ja, Herr Krieger, das ist möglich.
Dann machen wir das doch.
Perfekt, Herr Krieger. Ich setze sofort
den Vertrag für Sie auf.
Dann können wir sonst noch was für Sie tun.
Nein, vielen Dank.
Wann geht denn das los?
Wie sieht das aus?
Aufgrund von Corona haben wir momentan
extreme Engpässe.
Denn Sie haben momentan ja noch
das Modem von Hedron.
Sie brauchen eine Fritzbox.
Die V6091 kostet 200 Euro, Herr Krieger.
Und die kriegen Sie von uns natürlich
gratis in den Arsch geblasen.
Aber sie dauert einen Monat,
bis sie bei Ihnen ankommt.
Na ja, gut.
Ja, aber
habe ich dann irgendwelche Probleme mit meinem Internet?
Irgendwie wird es langsamer oder so?
Herr Krieger,
seien Sie unbesorgt.
Ja gut, das erzählen Sie ja immer.
Wir tun alles dafür,
damit Sie als Kunde da draußen
weiterhin mit Ihrer aktuellen
Leitung surfen können im Internet,
wie Sie es möchten.
Geil, danke. Vielen Dank.
Aufgelegt.
Ja, und lass mich raten, hat nicht geklappt.
Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt schon klar.
Nachdem dieser Hörer,
beziehungsweise nachdem dieses Telefonat
beendet worden ist,
hat die Dame einen Schalter umgelegt.
Das war quasi, ihr kennt es so aus dem Flugzeug,
diesen Schubhebel, die sitzt da
Das war meine Internetleitung.
Ab dem Zeitpunkt
hatte ich tagsüber
Ich hatte normalerweise immer so einen 20er Upload.
Ab dem Zeitpunkt
hatte ich tagsüber einen Upload
Hey, das kommt mir doch bekannt vor.
Das habe ich auch.
Das habe ich auch manchmal,
aber ohne, dass ich umgestellt habe.
Oh, kommt.
Was macht man als Businesskunde,
wenn man ein Problem hat?
Man wählt die Hotline-Nummer.
Drei Bit pro Sekunde natürlich.
... 800, die Nummer darf ich euch nicht sagen.
Ruf da an. Ja, schönen guten Tag, Krieger mein Name.
Ich bin Comaner Krieger, ich bin Businesskunde.
Herr Krieger, wir sehen das,
dass es hier auf unseren Monitoren ausschlägt.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Wir bringen Ihnen einen Techniker vorbei.
Geil, super, vielen Dank.
Aufgrund von Corona habe ich mir gedacht,
könnte es ja ein bisschen Probleme machen.
Das stimmt.
Zehn Minuten später kam der Anruf.
Schönen guten Tag, hier ist der Techniker,
ich bin morgen um 8 Uhr bei Ihnen.
Alles klar. Der Techniker kommt hier an,
wählt sich hier durch meine Wohnung,
misst an den ganzen Kabelmopeds hier alles durch.
Hier oben, Herr Krieger,
ich muss Ihnen sagen,
ich habe selten so gute Werte hier oben gesehen,
aber es gibt etwas da unten am Verteiler,
können wir in den Keller gehen?
Natürlich, wir gehen in den Keller,
wir gehen gemeinsam in den Keller.
Was ich jetzt viel cooler gefunden hätte,
wenn er mit der Kamera jetzt mit uns auch in den Keller gegangen wäre.
... angekommen wird, geschraubt, gebastelt.
Herr Krieger, Sie müssen nicht dabei stehen,
ich werde mich um diese Leitung kümmern.
Ich bleibe gerne hier, ich will das gerne sehen.
Ja, ja, ja, ich kümmere mich darum.
Er baut ein niegelnange neues Teil an,
was einfach nur scheiße
teuer aussah, man quatscht ein bisschen.
Kurze Frage,
wenn Sie sich jetzt nicht ausgewechselt hätten
und ich kriege diese mega, mega, mega
Pornoleitung von Vodafone,
wäre das dann, äh,
wäre die trotzdem so schnell?
Nein, Herr Krieger, dank dieses Verteilers
geht das hier richtig in Ihrem Haus ratzfatz.
Die Leitung bis zu Ihnen nach oben
ist wunderbar, aber bis zum Verteiler
von Ihrem Hausverteiler aus,
da habe ich leichte Schwankungen
gemerkt und das müssen wir ausgrenzen.
Dafür bin ich da.
Leichte Schwankungen, ah ja,
alles klar.
Dann wechselt alles aus.
Wir gehen nach oben.
Speedtest.
Besten Dank, hier nochmal
ein Zehner, alles Gute.
Happy Corona, mach es gut.
Der Typ ist unten raus,
fährt vorbei, was passiert?
Bei mir wird wieder das Internet
runtergefahren.
Ich denke mir, das kann doch nicht sein.
Dann rufst du 50 Mal
bei dieser Hotline an,
machst alle möglichen Testwerte,
haben sie schon mal den Router
neu gestartet, nehmen sie den Router
mal 10 Minuten vom Netz.
WLAN SSIDs.
Also André, WLAN SSIDs.
Musst du unbedingt, unbedingt
wechseln.
All den ganzen Fick, alles gemacht.
Ich spreche aus Erfahrung,
WLAN SSIDs.
Du warst schon verzweifelt.
Ich habe mitten in der Nacht gestreamt.
Warum? Weil tagsüber nichts passiert ist.
Ja, ja, die Techniker kümmern sich drum.
Ich habe die Nachricht,
hey lieber Kunde,
Unity Media ist jetzt Vodafone.
Und wir sind da für Sie.
Aufgrund von Corona,
oder Corona hat uns alle im Griff
und in Zeiten dieser schweren Zeit
müssen sehr viele Menschen auf Homeoffice zurückgreifen
und deswegen kann es zu Internetschwankungen
auch bei Ihnen kommen.
Wir arbeiten an einer Lösung.
Ihr Vodafone Team. Danke.
Jedes Mal,
jedes Mal habe ich so eine Nachricht bekommen.
3 Uhr nachts.
3 Uhr nachts ist das Homeoffice hier in Meerbusch.
Ja, wir haben hier die meisten Millionäre
auf die Einwohner gesehen.
Hey,
die meisten Millionäre haben wir glaube ich
in Königstein im Taunus.
Aber nicht um 3 Uhr nachts.
Nicht um 3 Uhr nachts macht Onkel Erna hier Homeoffice.
Vorher hat es ja auch funktioniert.
So, aber ja,
okay, kannst du ja mal sagen,
wenn es der Download wäre,
der Download auf volle Lotse.
Aber der Upload,
da ist Feierabend gewesen.
Da ist Feierabend gewesen.
Schön, zwei M-Bild.
Ja, das haben wir auch öfters.
Warum lecken die das hier drauf?
Ja, weil hier Homeoffice, Corona, scheiße.
Tut mir aber leid.
So.
Ein Monat scheiß Internet.
Einen Monat scheiß Internet.
Es kommt ein Paket.
Ding Dong, Ding Dong, die Post ist da.
Die Fritzbox ist am Start.
Es ist die Fritzbox.
Ich nehme das,
ich packe die Fritzbox aus,
ruf erstmal bei meinem Businesspartner,
Unity Media aka Vodafone.
Schönen guten Tag, Herr Krieger.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe die Fritzbox bekommen.
Das freut mich für Sie.
Was kann ich denn tun?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt gerne wissen,
was muss ich tun,
damit die Leitung hier,
wissen Sie,
damit das hier richtig ist.
Ja, kommen Sie zum nächsten Mal.
Herr Krieger,
Sie schließen jetzt das Tetron-Modem ab
und schließen einfach die Fritzbox an.
Das dauert
maximal ein Stündchen.
Danach läuft der Drops.
Ist ja auch kein Ding.
Normalerweise klappt das aber wirklich.
Du stöpselst das Modem an,
stöpselst das neue Modem an
und dann haben die bei Unity Media
so eine komische Auto-Config-Geschichte laufen.
Dann startet sich
die Fritzbox zehnmal neu
und irgendwann geht's.
Auch vorher hier irgendwelche Probleme
und hier war alles scheiße,
hier lief alles nicht richtig so.
Ich guck mal nach, Herr Krieger.
Ich guck mal nach.
Die Modemwerte sind ganz schlecht.
Was sehen Sie?
Ich sehe eine Einstrahlung, sehr gefährlich.
Das haben Sie mir auch erzählt,
die Einstrahlung.
Das sehe ich auch hier.
Oh, das haben wir ganz vergessen.
Das habe ich ganz vergessen.
Die haben mir auch erzählt,
dass die Modemwerte ganz schlecht sind.
Das habe ich ganz vergessen reinzuschreiben.
Moment.
Das haben sie mir auch erzählt.
Die haben geschrieben,
entschuldige die späte Rückmeldung,
dass es ein Problem mit deiner Leitung gibt,
ist anhand der Werte und des Modemlogs
auf jeden Fall nachvollziehbar.
Der Node ist glücklicherweise nicht ausgelastet,
also muss das Problem woanders liegen.
Ich habe dazu ein Störungsticket erstellt,
bla bla bla bla bla.
Irgendwas mit Einstrahlung haben sie mir auch geschrieben.
Genau.
Ich kümmere mich um Sie, Herr Krieger,
und ich schicke sofort
eine urgent Mail
in unser System,
dass alle Techniker sich sofort um diese Einstrahlung kümmern.
Diese Einstrahlung darf nicht länger existieren,
Herr Krieger.
Aber ich hatte das jetzt einen Monat
und Sie sind der Erste, der es ist, Herr Krieger.
Ich kann Ihnen das nicht erklären,
warum meine Kollegen das nicht gesehen haben,
aber es ist eindeutig eine Einstrahlung.
Und diese Einstrahlung muss bekämpft werden.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich schließe die FRITZ!Box an.
Es sind die gleichen Kabel, nur mal so nebenbei.
Du hast nur ein anderes Stromkabel für die FRITZ!Box
als für das Filtermotor.
Der ganze andere Radar ist genau der gleiche.
Natürlich, warum sollte es dann was anderes sein?
Ich schließe den Scheiß an,
warte es eine Stunde,
mache einen Speedtest.
Es geht.
Und jetzt die Frage.
Liegt es am Homeoffice? Nein!
Es liegt nicht am Homeoffice.
Wenn dir irgendeine Scheiße erzählt wird,
ja, aufgrund von Corona haben wir hier viele Homeoffice,
du wirst einfach vertröstet.
Du wirst einfach vertröstet.
Ihr zahlt nicht weniger, habt eine schnellere Leitung,
ja, okay, ich bin glücklich.
Aber irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Und da wollte ich heute mal ein Video drüber machen,
das nur weil ich eine FRITZ!Box ausgetauscht habe,
wo wir gerade beim Thema sind,
gibt es eigentlich wieder FRITZ!Boxen zu liefern?
Es hat ja vorher ausgetauscht.
Ah, exzellent!
Und erst nachdem ich den Vertrag quasi geändert habe,
war ein Monat,
hat meine Leitung
in Bazeck nach Dutsche.
Ich hab gedacht immer, bin ich hier in
in der Mongolei?
Was ich halt, was ich auch
total
merkwürdig finde ist,
stimmt, er hat keine Connect-Box,
er hat irgendwie noch was älteres.
Ähm,
das wollte ich jetzt sagen,
dass die eigene Connect-Box quasi schlechter funktioniert so,
das leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein.
Ähm,
meint ihr es lohnt sich noch, wenn ich mir jetzt eine neue FRITZ!Box bestelle?
Weil, guck mal Leute,
bis heute ist nichts abgekackt.
Ich würde sagen, wir warten jetzt mal,
wir warten mal die nächsten paar Streams ab.
Und dann schmeiß ich die Connect-Box raus.
Ne, deswegen,
ich hol mir auch keine Vodafone FRITZ!Box,
ich hol mir wenn schon so eine.
Ich brauch eh eine, für die ganze VoIP und DECT-Geschichte.
Auf dem Connect-Box-Interface
darf nur ein Benutzer, ja ich weiß,
die 660 ist Müll.
Warum?
Weil es der Teufel, der Teufel, oder was?
5,5 Sterne, ja als,
als sagen die Amazon-Bewertungen da irgendwas.
Neues Mikrofon?
Ne.
Andere Settings.
Wann ist heute Bett?
So 10 Minuten oder so.
Übrigens schön, dass so viele dabei sind.
Liegt das daran, weil ich den Titel habe,
schlechter Stream feels Batman?
Die Leute sind nur da, weil sie Mitleid haben, oder?
Die sagen, alter, so schlechter Stream,
da müssen wir jetzt mal wenigstens hier einen zweiten Tab aufmachen.
Hehe.
Ihr seid
Gebeter hier.
Leute, hier ist nix F.
Es ist überhaupt nix F.
Ich seh's genau, dass nix F ist.
Ich hab ne Vorschau laufen.
Der Chat wieder, alter der Chat.
Guckt's euch an.
Keinerlei Paketfehler, aber F.
Was die, äh,
die, ja, aber warum ich mir keine
6, 5, 9, 1
irgendwie kaufen wollte?
Warte mal, wir haben uns das ja
zusammen angeguckt.
Achso.
Achso, ja genau, die war nicht lieferbar, deswegen.
Die war nicht lieferbar.
Sonst hätte ich mir die nämlich gekauft.
Warum nicht den Enterprise Modem von Cisco und Huawei?
Naja, weil ich mit einem Modem alleine
nicht weiterkomme.
Ich kauf mir nicht umsonst ne Fritzbox.
Ich hab ja schon ne Fritzbox und nen Speedport.
Ich tausche einfach die
olle Fritzbox
und das Speedport gegen ne neue Fritzbox.
Die ganze VoIP und DECT
ähm,
macht ja die Fritzbox auch noch.
Das heißt, ich brauch, ich brauch quasi
eh was, was das macht.
Warum Fritzbox nicht nen Router mit OpenWrt?
Wie gesagt, äh,
SIP und
DECT-Telefone.
Und das ist mit der Fritzbox einfach am angenehmsten.
Gibt's die eigentlich
grad irgendwo lieferbar?
Aktuell hab ich so,
aktuell hab ich meinen Mikrotik-Router,
ich hab die Connect-Box dran
und ich hab ne Fritzbox dran.
Die Fritzbox ist für die DECT-Telefone
und für äh, Voice-Over-IP,
SIP
und ähm, glaub das war's.
Und
das Speed, das Unity-Media
Connect-Box ist nur dafür da,
sich einzuloggen.
Notebooks, Billi, echt, da gibt's wieder eine. Easy.
Ach, jetzt vorbestellen.
Haha, debated.
Ich brauch das WLAN nicht.
Ich brauch das WLAN. Äh,
6.6.0, weil die 6.6.5.1
nicht lieferbar war. Was? Ne, ne,
6.6.5.1
gibt's doch gar nicht.
Oder?
Ne.
Wir haben's uns angeguckt. Es gibt nur zwei, die
DOCSYS 3.1 können. Da muss ich mir keine
neue Fritzbox kaufen, wenn ich mir mal nen Gigabit-Anschluss
hole. Ähm,
es gab nur die zwei.
So, also, wo gibt's denn noch welche?
Lagernd.
Gibt's nicht. What the fuck?
Was? Idealo ist das
neue Geilshals.
Ich verwende Idealo nie.
Das war für mich immer so ne Scamas-Seite.
Nie ausprobiert.
Auf Amazon gibt's sie bei anderen Anbietern.
Ja.
Ne.
Erstens ewig lange Lieferzeit und viel zu teuer.
So, verfügbar.
Auf, gib Gas.
Sofort
lieferbar.
Ja, das geht doch.
Was?
CYCLOTRON.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Super.
Danke, Preissuchmaschine. Perfekt.
Ähm, was haben wir als nächstes?
Mars.
Trans?
War hab ich das richtig gelesen, ja?
Anzeige ist raus.
Da weiß ich auch nicht, ob ich da bestell. Sagt mir auch gar nix.
IT-Boost.
What the fuck? Was sind das für Shops?
IT-Boost?
Gibt's da auch irgendwas, was man kennt?
Real.
Real, 370 Euro.
Wunderbar.
Vielleicht warte ich einfach noch ein bisschen.
Ich mein, aktuell scheint's ja halbwegs zu funktionieren.
Und ganz wichtig, wir müssen gucken,
wenn's jetzt wirklich
die nächsten paar Streams funktioniert hat,
dann komm ich auf das zurück,
was der Unity-Mediamann oder Frau,
weiß ich nicht genau,
geschrieben hat.
Nämlich, ich zitiere das nochmal,
wenn alles wieder läuft,
kannst du uns gerne wieder schreiben,
dann können wir uns um eine entsprechende Gutschrift kümmern.
Ich brauch die Kohle nicht,
aber mich würd's einfach mal interessieren.
Was hat eigentlich,
was hat eigentlich die Telekom auf meinen dämlichen
Tweet geschrieben?
Clown-FPS.
Äh,
Assassin's Creed Valhalla war doch gar kein Ingame-Material.
Gar nix.
Ja, wär auch merkwürdig, was sollen die auch da drauf schreiben?
Was sollen die so blöden?
Was sollst du so'n Blödsinn auch schreiben?
Ignorant.
Ich suche momentan eine Mög...
SirSybot schreibt,
ich suche momentan eine Möglichkeit,
LTE in einen Raum
zu boosten.
Äh.
Gibt es LTE-Repeater?
Nee.
Keine Ahnung.
Ehrlich gesagt, kein Schimmer.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wirklich, null.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm.
Also,
aber man muss auch sagen,
generell, die ganze Repeater-Geschichte ist ziemlicher Crap.
Also es ist viel besser,
auch wenn man sein WLAN irgendwie erweitern will,
es ist viel besser,
wenn man den Netzwerkkabel
irgendwie noch hat,
verlegen kann oder Anschlüsse hat,
noch mehr Access Points hinzustellen.
Mehr Access Points sind besser als
irgendwelche Repeater-Lösungen.
Das ist so eine absolute, ähm,
Notlösung.
Bei der ganzen, bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Ähm.
Und was wirklich viel bringt,
die meisten Leute sagen immer,
totaler Schwachsinn, muss man gar nicht...
Was wirklich viel bringt, sind zwei Sachen.
Erst, also mal angenommen, man ist auf der Terrasse
und hat keinen richtigen WLAN-Empfang.
Zwei Sachen, die wirklich was bringen.
Erstens, mal gucken
und nicht
den Router automatisch
den Channel bestimmen lassen.
Sondern mal ausprobieren, auf welchem Channel
das Ganze am besten funktioniert.
Ein bisschen bessere WLAN-Access Points
haben so eine Funktion, wo man das messen
kann, quasi wie
ähm, voll
eine gewisse,
ein gewisses Band ist
und können das ganz gut machen.
Also diese UniFi-Access Points,
der und der Nano HD,
die können das eigentlich ganz gut.
Automatisch. Allerdings,
ich habe meine Sachen auch mittlerweile
fest eingeschaltet.
Und zwar hat mein Access Point oben
ein bisschen andere Channels,
wie mein Access Point unten,
bei manchen Sachen.
Und das hat wirklich was gebracht.
Und eine Sache,
die fast nirgendwo erwähnt wird, ist,
wenn ihr wirklich so an der Grenze seid,
beispielsweise ihr habt ein Tablet oder ein iPhone,
ihr seid auf der Terrasse
und ihr seid so gerade an der Grenze,
so scheiße, mal geht die Verbindung, mal geht die Verbindung nicht,
guckt, dass ihr es über 2,4 GHz macht.
2,4 GHz
geht weiter als 5 GHz WLAN.
Das ist aber das einzige,
was man machen kann.
Ansonsten ist es mit WLAN optimieren schwierig.
Es gibt natürlich
da noch die richtig coolen Leute,
die sich irgendeinen Outdoor-WLAN-Mesh
und was auch immer alles hinstellen.
Aber
jetzt wo ich die Dinger gerade auf habe,
die beiden Access Points kann ich tatsächlich empfehlen.
Das ist der bisschen ältere, das ist der neuere.
Der einzige Vorteil am bisschen älteren ist,
du hast 2 Netzwerk-Ports noch dran.
Ähm.
Ansonsten macht es keinen großen Unterschied.
Also die kann man wirklich empfehlen, die sind richtig gut.
Seitdem ich da oben,
ich habe oben den hier stehen und ich habe unten den hier stehen
und seitdem ich die beiden Access Points
am Start habe, habe ich
im ganzen Haus super Empfang, auf der Terrasse
super Empfang und überhaupt keine Probleme mehr.
Nun,
warum bist du subbt?
Weil dir der Tencent einen Sub geschenkt hat.
Wisst ihr, sogar der Chat ist mit den Unifys sehr zufrieden.
Und auch
das Web-Interface ist auch für Noobs ganz gut.
Ähm.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz das Web-Interface.
Gibt es da eine Demo, die man sich online mal angucken kann?
Weil meine will ich nicht zeigen.
Genau, das ist das Web-Interface
von den Access Points.
Das kann man sich auf dem Raspberry Pi installieren
oder man kann sich vom Hersteller was kaufen
für 50 Euro,
wo das dabei ist, so ein USB-Stick.
Aber ich empfehle es auf dem Raspberry Pi
zu installieren, das Web-Interface.
Wichtigste Sache ist, das Ding hat einen Dark Theme.
Ich finde es bloß gerade nicht.
Das Ding hat einen Dark Theme.
Das kann man anmachen.
Weiß aber gerade ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ah, hier oben. Da.
Bäm. Hallo.
Hallo.
Ah, yes.
So.
So, und das ist das.
So sieht das aus, wenn man ein paar Access Points hat.
Die haben natürlich hier etwas mehr drin.
Die haben hier 118 Access Points drin.
Bei euch wird das dann ein bisschen
ähm
nicht ganz so extrem ausschauen.
Ja. Ähm.
Also bei mir stehen da halt zwei Geräte
aktuell drin.
Aber die Verwaltung ist ziemlich easy.
Man geht nämlich hier einfach in die Settings,
sagt Wireless Networks, stellt hier irgendwie was ein,
was man haben will. Passwort,
WLAN-Name und dann drückt man Speichern
und dann rollt er das automatisch
auf allen connecteten
WLAN-Access Points aus. Also man muss das
gar nicht irgendwie selbst
konfigurieren. Man konfiguriert das über den Controller
und gut ist. Äh, ja.
Wohlgemerkt, mir geht es hier nur um die Access Points.
Von den anderen
UniFi-Geräten bin ich persönlich
nicht so überzeugt.
Also ich würde mir beispielsweise
keinen UniFi-Switch oder so holen.
Bei Routern und Switchen
schwöre ich ja auf MikroTik.
Ähm.
Einzige Ausnahme bildet bei mir
der Ubiquiti 10G
Switch. Ich habe ja den hier.
XG heißt das Ding, glaube ich.
Als Switch.
Würde ich mir heute auch nicht mehr kaufen.
Heute würde ich mir auch einen MikroTik-Switch
kaufen für 10G. Aber
damals hatte MikroTik, das war einer der ersten
preislich, ähm
ganz gut platzierten
10 Gigabit-Switches.
Der hat 12 Ports
SFP Plus
und 4 Ports RJ45
10G. Würde ich mir
heute nicht mehr kaufen. Heute würde ich mir einen MikroTik-Switch
kaufen wieder. Aber damals war es
der einzige. Kostet um die 500
Euro so in dem Dreh.
Ist aber, ist es ein guter Switch. Aber ich würde mir
trotzdem einen anderen heute kaufen.
Der beste Switch, Leute.
Den habe ich sogar noch da und den wollte ich nämlich mal
sogar give-awayen.
Vielleicht machen wir das sogar.
Im
Vielleicht machen wir das sogar mal im
im Stream. Und zwar
ähm. Es fragt
ja auch gerade einer, was empfiehlst du fürs LAN-Netzwerk?
Wie gesagt, ich, ich, ich mag
MikroTik-Switche.
Und ich habe folgenden noch
hier. Den da.
Das ist der beste
10 Gigabit-Switch für einen
Heimgebrauch, den ihr findet.
Der kostet nicht viel. Der kostet glaube ich
120 Euro.
Das ist ein richtig, das ist wirklich ein
absolut super Preis.
Für einen 10 Gigabit-Switch.
Du kriegst 4 10 Gigabit
SFP Plus Ports.
Einen Gigabit äh, einen Gigabit ähm
Kupferport.
Aber das Ding hat wirklich ein paar
richtig gute Highlights. Es gehört sich jetzt fast an
wie den MikroTik Werbestream.
Ich sollte vielleicht mal von MikroTik langsam Geld dafür
verwenden. Verlangen, dass ich den Scheiß immer so
bewerbe, ja. Ähm.
Aber nicht nur, dass du für 130 Euro,
120 Euro, 130 Euro
nen
Switch kriegst mit 4 mal
10 Gigabit SFP Plus.
Ne, du bekommst auch
Moment mal, gucken ob wir hier ein Bild haben.
Du bekommst auch einen Switch mit
redundantem Netzteil.
Mit 2 Stromanschlüssen.
Sowas kriegt ihr in dem Preis
nirgendswo.
Vergesst's. Nirgendswo.
Keine Chance.
Nicht mal doppelt und dreifach so teuer kriegt ihr das.
Und ähm
Was
Was daran cool ist für daheim.
Man brauch's nicht wirklich, ja.
Aber was daran richtig cool ist für daheim.
Was man zum Beispiel machen kann.
Ähm.
Dom PC, da komm ich gleich zu.
Was man zum Beispiel machen kann ist, man kann den in die Steckdose
stecken und den hier in ne USV.
Oder man kann hier ne Batterie dran
machen oder irgendwas, ja.
Ich mein klar, man könnte
es auch direkt in die USV stöpseln.
Aber es gibt da schon
mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Das finde ich ganz cool.
Und was man nicht vergessen darf, was auch ein ziemlich gutes
Feature ist. Der Port hier vorne.
USV zu Hause.
Klar, wer hat kein USV daheim.
Ähm.
Und der Port hier vorne, und das ist eigentlich fast noch
besser. Der Port hier vorne
kann POE.
Also sprich, wenn ihr zum Beispiel
ich hab ja den hier als Router.
Ich hab hier den Hex
POE als Router. Also ich könnte
diesen Switch
POE powern lassen von hier.
Das ist eigentlich cool.
Hat jemand LWL Verkabelung zu Hause?
Äh. Nee.
Ich hab's nicht im Haus gelegt. Ich hab bloß hier
bei mir oben, ähm, im
Arbeitszimmer hab ich
10 Gigabit.
Und ähm.
Ich verwende auch
bis auf die Verbindung
zum alten, zu dieser alten
4 HE Serverkiste
auch kein Glasfaser, sondern Direct Attach
Kabel. Einfach weil's viel
billiger ist.
Hat der immer noch eine Mini-USV? Nee, hab ich nicht.
Genau. Ja, also sowas
ist wirklich Feature-mäßig ist das Ding
absolut geil.
14 Gigabit Ports,
POE Port, redundantes
Netzteil für daheim.
Immer unabhängig davon, ob man das jetzt wirklich
braucht
und sagt, hier, anderes
kommt mir nicht in die Tüte.
Ihr kriegt für diesen Preis
ist das wirklich
absolut top.
Du kannst nix sagen.
Ohne das wäre das schon ein absolut geiles
Gerät. Aber damit und vor allem
dass du's über POE powern kannst, ist noch
viel besser. Allerdings Achtung, das ist nur
ein Gigabit Port. Also ihr könnt nicht
Gigabit und 10 Gigabit
ähm, POE machen.
Also richtig gut, das Ding.
Ach ja, und was ihr auch noch
wie gesagt, ich weiß, ich sollte da mal langsam
Geld von MikroTik für verwenden.
Ähm
Was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen?
Genau, ihr habt sogar die Auswahl, ob
ihr Router-OS verwenden wollt oder
Switch, ob ihr Router-OS oder Switch-OS verwenden wollt.
Router-OS ist das normale MikroTik
Betriebssystem auf ihren
Routern. Da kannst du wirklich Gott in die Welt
einstellen. Wer da keinen Bock drauf hat
und ein bisschen feature-reduzierte Oberfläche haben will,
nimmt Switch-OS.
Jo. Also,
super und in Kombination
wirklich erstklassig. Ihr kriegt für
200 Euro
das hier als 10 Gigabit Switch
plus diesen Router, da bezahlt ihr ungefähr 200 Euro
für. Das ist das beste
und günstigste, was ihr euch so
intern für euer Heimnetzwerk machen könnt.
So.
Hatte auch gerade einer gefragt
nach LAN-Geschichten.
Ähm, zeig uns mal
lieber ein analoges Telefon, was gut ist.
Excellent.
Schon mal auf einem Raspberry Pi 4 Windows
IoT installiert. Nö.
Habe ich auch nicht vor.
Wozu?
Eine Mini-USV. Ne, wie gesagt,
Mini-USV kenne ich nicht. Ich habe ja dieses Ding hier
am Start. Ähm,
Power. Oh, wie hieß das Ding?
Cyber.
Cyberpower. Ah, hier.
Das ist ja die USV, die ich am Start habe.
Aber, da ist die Batterie mittlerweile
kaputt. Und ich habe die Batterie
immer noch nicht getauscht. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen
USB-Ausfall habe, ist es RIP.
Ähm, die USVs sind teilweise gar nicht so teuer.
Die ist sogar noch einer der etwas
höherpreisigen, weil die halt im REC-Format
What the f...
Monkeys. Ähm,
äh, die von APC
haben ganz günstige,
die in so Steckerform sind.
Hier.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Oder sowas hier.
Oder sowas hier. Die hatte ich früher. Die hatte ich ganz früher mal.
Das ist einfach ein riesen Batterie-Pack
im Endeffekt.
Nicht verkehrt.
Falls es euch nur um kleine Sachen
geht, sagen wir mal ein Raspberry Pi oder so,
da habe ich ja schon vor einer Weile sowas gezeigt,
wo man das mit einer Batterie oder einem Akku machen kann.
Von, von AliExpress
bestellt. Man bekommt manchmal
Mikrotricks auch günstig auf Ebay, schreibt
dompc. Okay. Habe ich noch nie danach gesucht.
Schaut mal, die habe ich bisher immer neu gekauft.
USV ohne Batterie, klasse.
Die war mit Batterie.
Aber die Batterie ist kaputt gegangen.
Vor
vier, fünf Wochen.
Achso, dann doppelt NAT.
Weil die Fritzbox kann ja keinen Bridge-Mode mehr.
Die Fritzbox macht ja dann die Einwahl
direkt, direkt zu Unity Media.
Achso.
Ne, hä?
Würde gern auf dem Pi
eine .NET Core WPF-Anwendung laufen lassen.
Wow.
Ja, dann brauchst du tatsächlich irgendeine
Windows-Geschichte. Aber
ich würde mich wundern, wenn auf
Windows IoT WPF läuft.
WPF ist doch so eine DirectX-Geschichte.
Was hast du da für ein
VS Code Projekt mit Vodafone offen?
Die Ausreden, die Vodafone
bisher gebracht hat, wenn der Stream geleckt hat.
Okay, Leute.
Richtig cool, dass heute so viele dabei gewesen
sind. Ich weiß auch nicht, wo die alle hergekommen sind.
Nein,
der Stream ist nicht RIP.
Ich sehe es doch in der
Vorschau, Leute. Oh, der Chat.
Alter, meine Güte.
Chat, es ist gut jetzt.
So, ich schau jetzt mal kurz, dass ich keine Subs vergessen hab.
Lipziger. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die
vorher gelesen hab, aber wenn nicht,
Dankeschön für den tier-1-Sub.
Und Wupplan für 4 Monate.
Danke, habe ich glaube ich auch nicht gesehen.
Huge IQ-Sub.
Massive.
Nice-o.
Ne, die OBS-Stats blende ich
nur ein, damit ich den Chibayta
manchmal den Wind aus den Segeln nehmen kann.
Ich sehe es ja auf meiner Vorschau, dass hier nix
Frame droppt.
So, schön, dass so viele
dabei gewesen sind heute, Leute.
Vielleicht soll ich diesen Stream-Titel
das nächste Mal wieder nehmen. Der hat wohl gut
funktioniert. Wir hören uns
im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut.
Bis denn. See you.